good morning everyone
we'll call this meeting of the house
judiciary committee to order
and we'll begin with a
pledge of allegiance to the flag and if
representative page you could lead us in
that that would be
helpful
to the flag of the united states of
america and to the republic for which it
stands
with liberty and justice for all thank
representative gordon here
representative mclean
representative sylvia
representative welper is here
representative alexander
representative greene
representative notter
representative mirner
representative kelly
representative trottier
representative andrus yes representative
marjorie smith
representative burch
representative horrigan
i saw him didn't i see him come in
hi markhampton
representative diorenzo
representative chase
representative kenny
representative langley
representative macbeth
representative page
representative simpson
our first item of business this morning
that is a bill making immunity
immunization immune
[Music]
stat status a protected class
and the primary sponsor of that bill is
representative harvey bolia and
and
we'll call upon the representative to
introduce the bill and provide whatever
testimony she'd like to give the
committee
you have to turn on the microphone
thank you very much i'm uh as the chair
said i'm representative juliet harvey
boglia representing tilton and sammerton
in belknap district four
and i'm here to introduce the bill
house bill
an act making immunization status a
protected class
um
briefly i'm not going to go through
uh it line by line certainly
it's
it's a bill
to add to the protected class status
under the civil rights
laws
which already have identified
protected classes such as age sex
gender identity race creed color marital
status familial status physical or
mental disability
or national origin and add to that
immunization status
such or vaccine status as
as it's more commonly known
um
so
a couple things it would expand uh i
believe that this is simply an expansion
of
what we already have identified as
physical and mental disability
and it would give the equal protect give
the
protection under the law
i chose immunization status instead of
vaccine status because it's a broader
definition
which could it could imply uh
vaccine is is very limited and and
there's debate on what exactly you know
if the coveted vaccine is indeed a
vaccine
so this bill would imply
would
would protect
those
under employment laws housing laws
and public accommodation under those
it's rather straightforward so i don't
know that we need a huge discussion on
it
it would simply uh
the conversation about where what your
vaccine status is
while you're applying for a job or
so
you know
what is a civil right i'm you're in
judiciary so i'm sure all of you are
very familiar with that
um it's the rights of citizens to
political and social freedom and
equality
uh civil rights are a class of rights
that protect individuals freedoms from
infringement by governments social
organizations and private individuals
a common argument against making
the vaccine status a protected class
is that unlike your gender or color
i would say that that is not entirely
true since
some physical disabilities
a case can be made those can be
controlled
also gender identity
that's certainly a gray area
another argument against it would be
that
you are
expanding
government
so so to speak
in a broad way adding an additional
regulation
i would say you know that's certainly
one way to look at it but that's
not the only way to look at it and
certainly civil rights
are important um
especially uh in this
time
time and age when personal health
autonomy
seems to be
a
growing concern
i think it's
probably going to be the concern of our
age
and the next decade
so which side are are you all going to
be on
as far as this civil right
another argument in favor of this is
that
cutting
persons of color out of the job market
due to their vaccine status is yet
another infringement
upon
people of color
they have if you looked i
checked on our new hampshire
data
statistics on vaccines
for the state of new hampshire last
night
and persons of color
and hispanics are by far the least
vaccinated people
in the state and that is uh
not
special to our state but is
a phenomenon across the country
so what we have is a
another layer of protection for those
who already feel disenfranchised
by the government
um
that argument has been made in colorado
for the same bill
there are bills across the country
similar bills
it's already passed in montana this bill
protecting
adding vaccination status as a protected
class
in colorado black community leaders came
forward to speak in favor of the bill
which would prohibit discrimination on
cove vaccine status they explain that
the black and latino community is highly
vaccine hesitant due to the government's
history of medical atrocities against
them so i ask you to consider that and
questions for the representative
representative notter
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question what made you go
with
this top
protected class over
conscientious conscientious objection to
shots
um this
this bill was something that
some individuals in the medical freedom
caucus
decided that we would put up and um
i volunteered to
follow up
yes was there any talk about having a
bill for a conscientious objection
um i'm not quite
sure
what you're referring to there are i
think there are
aren't there bills out there
that we're considering right now that
have to do with that
well that's what i was asking oh
i i don't i can't answer that that's
i'm sorry thank you
representative sylvia
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
this is mainly driven by the covid 19
and the
mrna
injection which is
put forward as
a solution
does that injection as far as you know
give you immunity to the disease or
it seems that there thank you for your
question
representative it seems that there is
widespread evidence that it does not
provide any protection
from contracting the disease of covid
thank you
representative horrigan
yes
first of all just let me clarify um
although you seem
we've already touched on that when you
answered representatives question which
is um
is this
immunization status this would like uh
apply to all vaccines not just the coven
19 but also like the many
vaccines that people were routinely
taking
for years without what with relatively
as far as i read this
thank you representative horrigan
it seems to imply that that it would be
applied to all immunizations as far as
again it's
pinpointed to employment
housing public housing and
laws pertaining to equal access
in housing status follow-up
you may yes
um
so you mentioned a uh
i guess you call it a civil right or
something called a natural right to
bodily integrity and
there's several
so the reason i'm going to go with that
is
does that give you a natural right to
spread a highly communicable respiratory
virus to other people around you
um thank you for your question
um i believe uh the recent supreme court
uh ruling
it
pointed out that
having
viruses is a natural condition of
humanity it's a universal condition
where
that's our natural state it's not an
unnatural state to have a virus if
that's what you're getting getting at
and i'm
not sure if that's what you mean
not really me understand viruses are
it's a lot we don't know about viruses
but they are everywhere and
most of them we've either are harmless
we've adapted to them but we do have
this one particular
kovid19 virus which is extremely deadly
it's killed um
going i'm going to say pretty close to a
million people in the united states and
even more worldwide so we have a
natural civil right to spread that
thank you for your question um we have a
natural civil right to to remain as
uh
bodily intact
um and i believe that was uh
discussed at the last house session and
passed its law is that we have a right
to bodily integrity
in a right from
although this isn't directly government
intrusion but yes i i believe that we
have a right to bodily integrity and to
and conduct ourselves as we always have
for
hundreds of years without
a myriad of
series of shots all
okay i guess so yeah i think
representative smith
mr chair um
i i'm
really working hard to understand
your position and
respect your right to be here and
present this to us
are you saying that there is no
circumstance under which
the government has any right
to interfere with the bodily
thank you for your question
representative smith
um not not as such um i don't
i that is not what this bill says
this bill is
only applies to
employment laws and the civil rights of
a person to remain bodily intact as they
always are naturally born
and not to be discriminated against when
when they are seeking housing
this would affect persons of color who
are seeking housing
and
who could be subjected to any number of
requirements for
shots which they may have reactions to
they may be pregnant
and and it's ill-advised that they get
shots
this is something that should be
time has come
well thank you i won't belabor the issue
at what point should
people be presumed to be carrying
viruses that are extremely hazardous to
thank you for your question
representative sylvia
um at what point
i'm not a medical um
i some
um
i i don't know how to answer that i'm
sorry do you have something to add to
that
representative sylvia
perhaps
should we
normally assume that everybody around us
okay thank you maybe that um clarifies
it
um
yes i i would say so i mean i agree with
that we are all potentially
carrying a disease at any time um
we have epidemiologists to help us
we have an epi epidemiologist in the
state we have public service
announcements and that this is how it's
always been for
for hundreds of years is is public
service announcements education
um
doing doing the smart things and to
prevent
virus
uh from spreading
um and i cannot speak to all the medical
i'm not going to turn this into a
medical
debate um
but
the more wide as far as i know and i'm
not a medical professional but the more
widespread a virus is
um the more
less the less lethal it is it seems um
from what i have researched with
viruses
viruses uh for instance this one with
kovid
sounds like it started out more lethal
the more it spreads
the more it is
becomes uh less deadly because it has in
order to survive it it
it has to
become less lethal so it can
carry from one person to another
and again this i don't want to get into
a medical
if you're worried about a widespread
disease it's not as as lethal as say a
disease i think some of the earlier sars
viruses
that happened
in the last decade were more deadly but
they burn out quickly because
they
they kill their hosts so um again i
don't want to get into the weeds with
that because i'm not all that
viruses
representative simpson
mr chair if i may i'm a little anxious
that we're broadcasting publicly to the
people of new hampshire and there is
some misinformation that
actually is not what our epidemiologists
of the state are telling us is being
shared over the world wide web just want
to register that thank you
thank you for your comment
are there other questions representative
lorenzo
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
could you please expand on your
statements that physical disabilities
sure thank you representative dilorenzo
um
i i think i said
that some physical disabilities
could be considered as something that
could be controlled
such as an overweight
possibly neglected their health
some of the the conditions that would
render a person
physically
to give them a physical disability
could pot could have a medical
professional would say that they could
have controlled those or prevented them
in some cases
um and so
does that clear that follow-up yes you
may follow up okay so when i think about
um physical disability i look at the
social security definition of disability
and
the qualifications for disability under
social security is that a person is is
sick they're unable to work the
condition is
could result in death um
and so i
i think there's sort of like a um
kind of a mismatch between what you're
defining as disability and what the
legal
definition of disability is
thank you
okay thank you
i guess i do i have a question okay and
and that is uh talking about
immunization status
right now our schools require certain
immunizations for children in order to
attend public schools and the supreme
court has upheld that in the past
as something that they're entitled to do
would if we put this into
does
would this
apply in any way or would affect
status um
i believe that um
that it is possible that uh
that this would affect
possibly schools um
in the same way that
gender identity
may
impact schools and protecting that civil
but
uh
it's remains to be seen how that would
go uh the schools might be separate
and they already have laws so
thank you and if i could just follow up
and this is the problem of being a
lawyer because
words are the
tools of the lawyers trade but
it mentions immunization immunization
statute and when you were saying you
said
currently the vaccine that is provided
for covid
may not provide immunization
so
if that's the case if it doesn't provide
immunization
um
rhetorical question maybe um
it that's why it was written broadly mr
chair immunization status
meaning
you could have immunity
from um simply having coveted
um
but that you know
and that's certainly a consideration
you've you've had covet so you have some
immunity but that's not
how this is uh working out for people so
they're not uh being allowed to
uh use their their immunity that they've
had from a past infection to their
credit um and avoid
getting a vaccine
um
it is it's it's
it's simply an intellectual um
you believe that that it is a civil
right
that needs protecting
um and and i think that it comes down to
that
would
and just as a follow-up to that question
is would it not be better to say
vaccination status as opposed to
if if i i would certainly be
um open to an amendment if the committee
felt that that was
appropriate
i was simply thinking of
the fact that
the coveted vaccine in it
as it is
it's an mrna
some some say it's an mrna
medical uh
device or
it's a it's a treatment but it's
technically not a vaccine so i was
simply thinking of future
it's not exactly a vaccine that you're
that there that say the government is
asking you to get
but it is
a gene therapy sort of
treatment that they're asking you to get
for the purpose of
viruses
to prevent viruses
so i was that's why i was thinking in
broad strokes about um
this
immunization status
because it's possible that in the future
it's they won't even call it a vaccine
perhaps but they'll call it you know
what it what what other people have
called it is mrna treatment or
other medical treatments
and and i guess an argument can also be
made that it could be
medical treatments
if i could just follow up one last time
and that is
could this not backfire in some cases
and i'm just thinking of
a noted tennis player where
you have a rule that says that you have
to
you have to
comply with certain requirements
but
if you already have immunity because
you've had the disease
that couldn't your immunity status
couldn't be taken into consideration so
you'd still have to comply like
if you had a law that said you had to
wear a mask
but you've already had the disease and
you're immune
this would say you can't take that
immunity statute into consideration that
immunity into consideration and
determining whether you have to wear a
mask
any number of issues could be
just like the other
thank you for your question other
categories here
age sex gender you know and all of those
any number of those could
backfire in any sort of
certain ways
i can imagine um
the gender identity there's this fraught
with
all kinds of complications
um and so i guess
that's why i didn't go into a
it
in you know an intense testimony because
it just sort of comes down to is it
a right that should be protected or not
i think
it's simple and do we want to
have make these cutouts and protect
people who don't want
medical um treatments and or vaccines
um or or do we not see it as something
representative silvia
thank you mr chair and you inspired some
questions for me uh the first one having
to do with uh school children and
discrimination
uh do you
would it be your understanding that
currently children are
essentially
put into various classes by the age
group and
some are discriminated against
perhaps
so thank you for the question
representative so the question is are
some children discriminated against
due to age
and it sounds like
i'm not sure what you're getting at with
are you trying to say that
discrimination is is sort of normal in
schools because age is
a category and how we categorize
children
um
i wouldn't say they're discriminated
against no they're
i wouldn't say it's a discrimination
um
or a civil rights violation that the
children
are
categorized by age in school
follow-up so i guess the the the the
point of that question is
or let me rephrase the question
so that it is a question
um
do you know of
the possibility that children can
uh file a suit because of discrimination
on on the basis of age if they feel they
are
discriminated against
would this apply
differently because of age or vaccines
vaccine
immunization status
thank you representative sylvia i do not
know of any
lawsuits
per se
that top
where the age is the subject matter
uh as a basis of a discrimination
lawsuit
although i
i i can recall in
in
that it has come up in the past
um i
where a student with
extraordinary you know abilities in
school wanted to
you know for instance skip grades or or
whatnot and they
weren't allowed
but i can't say i know of any specific
representative nader thank you mr
chairman
representative the chairman had
mentioned that shots are required for
children to go to school would you
believe that we have
in the law a religious exemption but we
do not have conscientious objection and
that's why i
asked about that earlier today
thank you representative knotter i i i
do know that's a
um something that is
uh
that we're just you know that we're
discussing right now at the house level
too
that is something that did not come up
when we were writing this bill but i
representative sylvia
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my additional question
earlier it was suggested that we might
change this to vaccine status as opposed
to immunization status
are you aware
that the cdc has
changed the definition of vaccine over
the years
thank you representative sylvia i
i was aware
and i had heard that the cdc had changed
it
it makes it difficult
thank you mr
chair i um
i hesitate because i think it
might be time to
permit the sponsor to
retire to another seat and let other
people come but
um i have
as the first staff member
of the equal employment opportunity
commission which was created title vii
of the civil rights act of 64.
uh
and
being somewhat aware of
the definitions of civil rights
and
how they have evolved over the years in
this country
i'm
stumbling a little bit to
try to understand
how
this issue fits in
to a civil right
but
let me follow up on one of the questions
that one of my colleagues asked
do you think it would be
a
legitimate
case if
um
someone
representing the interests of a
three-year-old
since i think we all recognize that the
three-year-old could not represent her
own interest
but someone representing the interests
of a three-year-old
could sue
the government
for
under
current conditions not
permitting
the three-year-old to be vaccinated
on the government's theory that there is
not yet appropriate verifiable evidence
that that would be the safest thing for
that child
would that
case have standing
because that child's civil rights are
being
denied and that that child's
representative can't
insist on
vaccination or immunization whichever
thank you for the question
representative i'm not sure if i fully
unders let me repeat back
would i think that there's a problem if
there was somebody representing a
three-year-old who didn't want it the
three-year-old didn't want to get
vaccinated or the parent i'm sorry the
three-year-old the representative who
has standing in the court to the parent
of the caregiver or whomever
did want the child to be
vaccinated but in fact no
responsible medical provider
would provide
that vaccination or immunization until
such time
as the appropriate government agencies
say it would be safe for a
three-year-old
and
but the uh the person responsible wants
to jump the gun and say i want my i want
this civil right to be honored and have
this child vaccinated
the government would say no
right now six weeks from now they might
say yes as new research and testing
demonstrates that it is safe for very
young children but right now it's not
but someone believes their civil rights
are being
to
you when when you build a wall you have
to figure out what you built what you're
walling in and what you're walling out
and you're looking at it from the point
of view of no vaccination but it's what
about the other side
of someone who wants a vaccination okay
i think i understand the question
representative but
um
this isn't
this isn't really about forcing vaccines
or or taking
vaccines
and the in the particulars about
when they should be administered or if
they should be administered to a child
or the medical advice as it changes
constantly with regard to covid and
you know now we're looking at them
possibly vaccinated children that are
five
um for the code vaccine but it is
really more of a theoretical
argument a civil war is it a civil right
or should it be a civil right
that um
people should have equal protections
under the law
to remain as they are
unvaccinated
um
and under
and and given these protections it's
theoretical and it's not
there we could probably
do these
special you know what what ifs all day
but it's it's more i think
theoretical
um certainly there's a case to be made
for we can discuss what ifs quite quite
a bit and i could probably take gobble
up quite a bit of your time but
the way i see it
when i wrote this and thought of it is
it is not much different than a physical
disability
or
a choice such as
gender which you could construe gender
identity could be you know some people
choose to be this or
they feel that they are another gender
or marital status is also a choice
um
so
i'm gonna leave it at that
representative thank you for your
we
have
sorry are we on
thank you
my name is kathy bizarothemberg
executive vice president with the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all 26 of our state's
community hospitals as well as all of
our specialty hospitals
the new hampshire hospital association
is opposed to house bill 1260. the bill
before you
would make immunization status a
protected class
we do not believe it's appropriate to
include immunization status as a
protected class under the state
constitution of human rights
this committee heard a similar bill last
week house bill 1519 which we also
testified in opposition
this bill as well as other bills before
this committee attempts to insert
additional classes into the statute that
protects individuals from discrimination
which is not appropriate
we believe all these bills are focused
on without explicitly stating such an
attempt to insert vague language into
the statute against the covet 19 vaccine
the result of all these bills would just
lead to lawsuits and further confusion
among employers and employees
it's our position that employers have
the right to determine what is best for
their employees and their clients their
patients and or their patrons
requiring vaccinations of healthcare
workers from communicable diseases is
not new for our hospitals in new
hampshire hospitals have required
vaccination against several communicable
and deadly diseases such as mumps
measles rubella chickenpox diphtheria
tetanus pertussis and influenza as a
condition of employment with the same
type of medical and religious exemptions
allowed for the covit 19 vaccine
we believe requiring vaccinations is
absolutely the right thing to do for the
health and safety of our patients our
staff and the citizens of new hampshire
the vast majority of hospital staff have
been vaccinated against coven 19 or have
received exemptions and we've heard from
many health care workers who support the
vaccine requirement to protect their
health and that of their patients that
they're caring for
so in conclusion we are opposed to house
bill 1260 and we urge this committee to
find the bill in expedient to legislate
thank you very much for the opportunity
to present our testimony
are there questions
representative sylvia
thank you for taking my question
just last night we had a conversation
with our county
nursing home administrator
who told us that
with the possibility that
a third injection would be possibly
mandated by cms
that 60 percent of the staff would not
take it
d do you see that as a threat to the
medical system
for our hospitals experience we have not
seen that number at all i'm not sure
what his experience his or her
experiences with that particular nursing
home and their staff
we have found that
the vast majority of our hospital staff
have taken the vaccine as a mandate and
has not had a major impact on
their
employment
follow-up
so
would you say that staffing levels have
not been affected by those who are
resisting the injection
right now all of our hospitals have gone
through the process of mandating the
vaccine we have seen a very small number
of individuals who decided to
remove themselves from employment from
our hospitals we have had
even before the pandemic
nursing shortages so
we
understand the
risk of requiring vaccines for
healthcare workers but again the vast
vast majority have taken the vaccine
representative horrigan
yes too i'm also on a county
county delegation executive committee
and this topic came up
in stratford county and what
what we were told was that there's near
vaccination rate amongst the staff at
the rest home and also
amongst amongst the patients who are
healthy enough to go through it so is
your experience is traffic county more
typical or is belknap county where we're
just told supposedly 60 of the staff are
refusing to get vaccinated or is it
so is it
where is it in between those two
extremes
yeah right
is there a question specifically related
yes which which of those
two data points have been cited as as to
mr chairman
the representative
misrepresented my remarks
i said that our
nursing home administrator said that if
a third injection is required
her opinion is that 60 percent of the
staff will not take it i did not say
that 60 had not taken it
thank you
i apologize if it didn't make myself
clear but i was also
we also heard that there is little of
any resistance amongst the staff so um
maybe
that's two different homes two different
committees so i think you've made your
point so thank you
there any other questions representative
lorenzo
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question now um if this bill
were to pass would it affect payments
from medicare
i think there are other bills that have
a more direct impact on
the federal requirements for mandates
for health care workers to receive
the
cobin 19 vaccine
i'm not a lawyer to understand if this
particular bill would have
a direct impact on their federal
reimbursements however i think
we have a serious concern with
trying to insert immunization status as
a protected class because
we as a healthcare profession or
healthcare industry are requiring
vaccination for employment
other questions you have another
question representative sylvia
yeah so what you're saying
if i can
ask this
you are currently discriminating against
people who have a natural
immune system
i'm sorry um representative but that is
incorrect um
copenhagen 19
vaccination is a requirement for
employment it has nothing to do with
natural immunity from someone who has
received who has contracted coping 19
and in fact we highly encourage those
who have contracted copenhagen to still
see none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
i see this i'm in support of this bill i
see this bill as uh protecting civil
rights because of the amount of
discrimination that
occurs for people who have chosen not to
take the vaccine
in addition
i consider this
personal
protected medical information
that
we should not have to share with other
people
if i were to take a survey
around the room here and
ask people although i meant policy would
say that i shouldn't ask questions but
if i were to ask people to raise their
hands around the table
to share their medical information with
me
i would ask questions like um have you
raise your hand if you've been treated
for
std or
raise your hand if you've had your tubes
tied
raise your hand if you have cancer
raise your hand if you've
been treated for mental illness
imagine now that
a school teacher is in a room of
elementary students and
is asking
the children
raise your hand if you're not vaccinated
imagine
the
kids who are not vaccinated because of
choice
by now we're going to be
discriminated
recall the famous
film
back in the 50s of the brown eyed
students and the blue eyed students
this is a discrimination
how did we get there how did we get here
to this
day where we're trying to consider
vaccine
status a civil right
well briefly
started out with fear the four-letter
word
f word fear
way back when when the
24 7 news reporting on this pandemic
people dying
[Music]
of this terrible disease
and
eight hundred thousand people are dying
of this terrible disease
with coba but not of covet by the way
so we have the fear and fear is a very
powerful
emotion it disarms people
how do we get out of the fear
what do we offer them
hope
how do we
what kind of hope can we provide
well
we have no treatment for this
disease
says the cdc
who
[Music]
never
imagined the center for disease control
you would think they would have hundreds
of clinical trials across the country
when this broke out
no
no we're not going to try to treat this
acutely we'll just wait till people get
sick
and
go to the hospital get on a ventilator
and see how they do
but we have hope we have a vaccine the
only hope is a vaccine and this was
touted
forever
got to get a vaccine our only hope out
of this
we can
but it's going to take a couple years
because historically vaccines have to go
through a huge process of
safe trials safety trials and other
trials
oh but look
suddenly we have a vaccine after a year
this experimental vaccine emergency use
authorization
well even though the safety data wasn't
there let's let's
because we need to allay the fear let's
get this vaccine out
then the vaccine came out people were
signing up left and right
people couldn't wait to get their
vaccine
i want to be first in line
i'm going to be late for my appointment
because i have to call to get my vaccine
appointment
well
some people feel it's their right their
human right not to have things injected
into their body especially for something
that has not been proven to be
safe and effective and i say that and
sharing misinformation which is a
convenient phrase to cancel people
but
the cdc's own vares reporting system has
reported over
twenty thousand deaths thought to be due
to the vaccine
this number is probably underestimated
in the same way that the original deaths
so now we have this
vaccine status which is the holy grail
everyone wants to be vaccined and we
don't want to be around people that are
unvaccinated
i just share some stories of my own
every year i lead a kayaking trip with a
bunch of people
and we fill out a spreadsheet
include what you're going to bring for
potluck what sort of community items
you're going to bring for the trip
and everyone on the trip can i can edit
the spreadsheet
the spreadsheet is blank and i'm still
waiting for people to add their
information to the spreadsheet and
suddenly someone writes down
a column vaccine status
and
bing bang that thing gets filled up
and i said to someone say you know we
don't we don't need to share that
information
vaccine status
oh yes i have a right to know if you're
vaccinated
i've had my vaccine and i need to know
if anyone else
is unvaccinated
why do you need to know that if you
believe in the vaccine you took the
vaccine do you really what are you
afraid of are you
like i'm going to infect you because um
[Music]
unvaccinated and considered someone
maybe like i had leprosy or some such
thing
uh another instance is my wife wanted to
have a long-term knitting friend over
and
we would
she would sit in the driveway
spread
10 feet apart
the woman
emailed her and said to her i'm sorry
but
i hear that you're unvaccinated and i
really can't come to your house and knit
so i consider uh this
bill as something that we're seeing
discrimination
with people who are unvaccinated not i'd
like to just add another example that um
is a local one a local business
is allowing people who are vaccinated
come to their venue on thursday nights
but only if you bring your vaccine
passport which is another whole
legislative issue
um and
when you come on thursday we'll even
serve food to you
but if you come on friday or monday now
you can't have our food
so i see this as a discriminatory
class of people that we're ending up
with the so-called unvaxed the dangerous
bugaboo
people that we have to be wary of
so um
i'll take any questions
thank you
thank you for your testimony um
it sounds like to me that you may be or
are you familiar with dr mark mcdonald
mark mcdonald no
okay
are there any other questions
may i ask who that is or why the
question or i can't
can't do that unfortunately we get that
ani
malachi
good morning everyone my name is ani
malachi i am the executive director for
the human rights commission
and
my
testimony today is more informational
than anything i'm certainly
open to any questions that you all might
have for me
we the commission is not taking a
position on hb 1260 um but uh
i'm here for any any questions you might
have i've listened to the previous
testimony maybe i can shed light there
may be some issues where i cannot but
i'll certainly do my very best
one of the things i would like to say
before i turn it over to you all for
questions
when we looked over the legislation
there were questions for
us
relative to the definition where it
talks about immunization status
in that definition it talks about
employment specifically however our
statute
and and further on in in house bill 1260
it does include
public accommodation and
housing however the definition is very
specific
to employment only
i think someone asked earlier relative
to education and as of 2019 the
commission
also covers k-12 public education
so i would
think this would possibly apply to that
as well
but maybe there's an amendment to to fix
the
that portion of the
of the definition that only speaks to
employment however the rest of the the
bill speaks to at least two of the other
areas that we currently cover
um
and
with that said if there are any
questions for ms malachi
thank you for taking my question uh
broadly speaking
it's the commission on human rights and
then it also speaks of civil rights
could you just clarify for us
the
difference if there are any uh between
the two terms
um thank you very much for your question
um i've been the executive director for
about four years i have that question
daily
we get lots of calls from lots of people
and so the title of the organization is
the commission for human rights however
what we do is we enforce
rsa 354-a which is based upon the
title vii of the civil rights act
so
the naming of the organization is a
little confusing but you would have to
speak to
those that preceded me and created this
representative sylvia
have there been any
complaints brought against employers who
are discriminating against people who
have
a natural
immune system that they believe they
thank you so much for the question um so
we have really strict confidentiality um
within our agency um what i would need
to do is circle back with you to tell
you statistically speaking if we have
had any charges
but the way the law is written right now
people can
exert a religious or medical exemption
so those are the areas of which that
people have a right to to make to assert
their
freedom i i guess if you want to say it
that way
since immunization status is not
something that we currently cover then
we wouldn't have any charges there
have people called about that i would
have to look to see if there have been
any questions
and then really
look at the rule to make sure that i
could share that information publicly
but the the long answer to the short
question
we do not currently cover immunization
status so
there would not be any statistical
information relative to immunization
status
representative sylvia would you like to
follow up
i'll uh i'll let the chairman know that
he should have his gavel handy for this
question
some people
would consider
not being vaccinated as a mental
disability
would that be
protected
by your agency
so
being thank you for the question um
being discriminated against based on
your mental or physical disability is
something that we would cover
we look to the ada so
if if there was a question there we have
whatever legal precedent provided to us
by the if it's in employment um the eeoc
who we partner with is our federal
partner we certainly have the ada to
look at and if there's nothing there and
we have additional questions then we
would certainly refer those questions to
the attorney general's office whose job
it is to interpret the statutes as as
they are so written for the state of new
hampshire
i guess the only question i have is uh
in terms of
this being added to the statute
being immunization status
do you see
is this would this be viewed any
differently than any of the other
categories that are in the statute do
you see any issues or problems with
enforcement
thank you very much that's a great
question
we would cover this as we do as we would
anything else that's currently written
in our statute
the question would then move forward in
terms of volume
because if you're looking at
immunization status this is broadly
written
and so it could cover anything any
immunization
it would cover k-12 education it would
cover
people relative to their employment or
housing or being able to or not able to
walk into a venue or a store
so
there could be a possibility that we
would have a lot of charges walk through
the door
and we could also not have very many
charges walk through the door
unfortunately that would be very
difficult at this point to to ascertain
what the
if there would be a tsunami
or if there would be
very very few charges and
uh and and so to answer your question
more specifically
yes we would handle these the way we
would age race sex gender any of the
areas of uh discriminate discrimination
and i just sort of want you you've
provoked another question by your
response and and that is
not to be pejorative but some delay in
the way cases have been processed people
have complained at times about how long
it takes to process through the human
rights commission
and
given that this is an issue which might
is there an issue at all with regard to
the handling the volume of potential
claims thank you very much for the
question and the opportunity to share
some breaking news as it were
so
with the number of investigators that we
have which is five
and we cover the entire state is that
number something that should be
increased absolutely do all agencies ask
for increase in staff of course they do
however
for the process that we follow
having more hands is immensely helpful
since becoming the director of the
agency
more recently i have looked at how we
are staffed and what staff is doing what
so with this last budget cycle added a
paralegal which has been
unfortunately is just a part-time
position however it has been immensely
helpful with shifting some of the burden
that would have fallen to certain
investigators and or the assistant
director
to work on motions for reconsideration
and other of our more legal elements so
it has shifted that burden um and it is
working very well
along with that um the staff the
assistant director myself and our staff
along with our
help
from the ag's office our client services
representative went through a very long
process of working together to change
how we are processing our cases to
create a more efficient process
it obviously follows the statute and it
follows the rules but looking at
timelines and looking at how we can
shore up what we're doing and how to
make the process move faster for
complainants as well as respondents you
know when a respondent gets a letter
they would like to move through this
process as quickly as they can
and when a complainant files a charge
they would certainly like to have the
opportunity to have their
their voice heard and if their financial
if there's financial compensation that's
needed they would certainly like to have
that in a much faster form
one of the things that had happened over
time with the agency is there was some
turnover so
see some people were leaving to seek
other employment to do something
completely different there were
attorneys or new attorneys young
attorneys who had young meaning length
of time practice not age
were not discriminating here
but
attorneys who were new in their legal
career who could not afford to continue
to work for the agency with school loans
etcetera and so what happens is when
each
investigator has a caseload and any
investigator for whatever reason is no
longer employed with the agency their
caseload moves over and it's divided
amongst the other
investigators that are remaining so they
have their current caseload whatever
additional cases that were given and
currently uh or previously the case load
was set at 50
which is not a sustainable or workable
model and so we have revamped that as
well
so they're going through all of their 50
cases plus the others that they were
assigned and then when those get done
then you start going into the cases that
have been
that have come in and so what we're
looking at is really restructuring how
many cases are assigned initially
looking at the timelines that are given
and there's a letter that will go to the
bar to explain what this process is and
to prepare them for things to move a lot
faster
to avoid the opportunity for
cases to sort of sit with us until
certain practitioners are ready to move
them forward but all of this is in the
name of the agency working better for
both parties not just one
given given all that
additional work that might be provided
by the proposal
is that a problem at all
it might be
i would not say
no and then in
a year we need three more additional
people
the issue is that there is no way of
knowing for example in 2019 when
education was added
the difficulty was oh my gosh you know
all of the k-12 schools and charter
schools have an opportunity to file
charges and there was just no way to
understand how many and so i could
foresee a flood of charges and
statistically speaking that has not
happened so
it's very difficult to say yet i leave
my hand partially open in case i need to
come back to
request additional bodies to help
thank you you're welcome any other
questions
thank you mr chairman um
and thank you for taking my question um
miss malachi
now um
when i look at this bill
it makes me wonder how
vaccine status could become a protected
class
because when i think of a protective
class the um characteristics are
immutable
such as except for religion immutable
such as race gender
sexual orientation gender identity
disability
in national origin those characteristics
are
immutable
and generic
so how
would vaccine status fit into that
scheme
as being a protected class
thank you very very much represent
representative lorenzo for the question
um
you are 500 correct yes the the 1964
civil rights act um
preventing discrimination is based on
immutable characteristics
the short answer to your question is
if the if the
legislative body decides that this is
something to be added to our statute
then it is our the commission's
responsibility to move forward with
enforcement of that additional
xenon thank you for your testimony today
i have no other cards is there anyone
else who would like to testify today on
yes sir
you can turn on the microphone
and identify yourself
yeah this is my first time doing this so
i'll try to
maintain my composure here my name is
wayne i live locally um
uh
this is all new territory that we're in
some of the things that this gentleman
mentioned i've seen at
where i work
there are there are certain exemptions
there weren't many that i know of i'm
not at the level where i would have that
information
but what i've seen personally um
people are already being discriminated
against
whether
if they eat with co-workers or so
they're vacs they're unvexed
if they change in their locker room
they're vexed or unvexed
um
i'm not an anti-vaxxer i was in the
military i've received many
vaccinations um
i think you know
the schools require it but i don't think
the schools
um
to my knowledge there are certain kids
that get that that don't get vaccinated
for whatever reasons the school doesn't
tell the rest of the students or the
families that they either had the shot
or not um
so
if you have if you just put a label on
it as whether you have it or not
i guess that's my issue
that's why i think it should be
protected information you shouldn't have
to
let it be known whether you have it or
not
so
thank you
do you is there anyone with a question
yes
which way no okay thank you and thank
you wayne for taking my question
you mentioned in the hospitals right now
where
people are say you're in the lunchroom
um is it known between people who's
vaccinated and who is not are you saying
it's like a school system where you have
uh the hospital or whoever i mean
they have to protect the rights of the i
don't you know they're not going around
telling people but it is known that
people know
i mean obviously in that you know in our
line of work
you pretty much don't have a choice you
have to get it or so and there's very
few people that haven't gotten it for
whatever reason
but the people that have not gotten it
it's those people
people other everybody else knows who's
they are
um
i do i don't treat anybody differently
i'm not afraid of anybody whether they
have it or not
and i also contracted covid so
i mean and there's a lot of people i
know that had the vaccine
within the institution that have gotten
covered so
it's not a magic it's not a magic
bullet
i have other family members an entire
family of seven in total that did not
receive any of those vaccines or
treatments whatever you want to call
them and they they recovered on their
own
so i'm just saying like me personally
i've witnessed you know
um i mean like to come into this room we
didn't have to tell anybody anything you
know i just walked in here i brought a
mask out of respect but once i found out
i didn't need to wear it i didn't but
nobody has to consult with anybody to
come into this room to sit at this table
we're just here
speaking as people
so basically to just i've witnessed the
thank you for taking my question
thank you are there other questions
representative lorenzo thank you mr
claire and thank you for taking my
question um you had said that at your
work setting that people who are
unvaccinated everybody knows um how do
i can't say exactly how people know but
maybe the some of the people that have
not gotten it have talked about it
openly or they're not afraid and that's
their personal right
but to just
put it out there that
it has to be known that's because that's
how i feel this is being
we're trying to you know i feel like
this bill is basically saying
that you don't have a right to know
whether or not i've received it or not
that's how i perceived it but the people
that know
that you know the majority of people
that know who who has and has not is
because
those people are that did not get it for
whatever reason
they're making it known but that's their
choice that it's not like the employers
or had came out and you know you that's
you can't do that
thank you thank you for the
clarification okay
seeing none thank you for your testimony
we we do require you to fill out one of
these pink cards and submit it
before you leave okay
thank you very much wayne
anyone else wish to testify on house
seeing no one we will close the hearing
on house bill 1260 and we'll be in
recess until our next hearing which is
we'll call this
meeting of the house judiciary committee
back to order
our next item of business this morning
is a hearing on house bill 1490 fn an
act relative to equal access to places
of public accommodation regardless of
vaccination status
and we'll call upon the prime sponsor
representative kamtois
to
introduce the bill and provide her
testimony
thank you mr chairman honourable members
of the judiciary committee
i am here before you today to discuss hb
1490 equal access to public
accommodation a civil right
rsa 354
deals with human rights and laws against
discrimination
civil rights revolve around the basic
right to be free
from unequal treatment
civil rights laws prohibit
discrimination
civil rights are a class of rights that
protect individual freedoms
from infringement by governments
social organizations and private
individuals
they ensure one's entitlement to
participate in the civil and political
life of society
and the state without discrimination
or repression
discrimination
is the practice of unfairly treating a
person or group of people differently
from other people or groups of people
all people
are created equal
and discrimination of any kind should
not be tolerated because of a person's
personal decision
anti-discrimination laws
protect those in the minority whether or
not you agree or disagree with them
enshrined in our declaration of
independence
is the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness and it is the duty
of this legislature to protect those
individuals from being discriminated
against
this bill is very simple
it says that you cannot be discriminated
against for vaccination status
we have hipaa laws on the books that
protect our medical privacy
yet we are now asking people for their
vaccination status in order to receive
services or to enter a public
accommodation
in my opinion we should not even need
any of these commissions because nobody
should be discriminated against for any
reason
no matter what we should all be treated
equally under the law
it should be very simple
but we now have created classes of
people
we have a law so that we don't
discriminate based on your sex
your marriage status your physical or
mental disability we have to keep
putting into statute all these
exceptions so that people are not
discriminated against it is unfortunate
that we have come to this point
but nobody should be discriminated
against and nobody should be not be
denied access
to any public accommodation
i am open for questions
questions representative horrigan do you
have a question
okay um thank you very much mr chair
thank you very much brother come troy
so do you feel that there is a
civil or natural right to
spread a communal communicable disease
well thank you for the question mr
horgan
communicable disease representative oh
sorry
my mind was somewhere else sorry
is it right
no
but does it happen
all the time
we don't discriminate people because
they have herpes we don't discriminate
against people because they have
gonorrhea or any sexual disease
so please we should not discriminate
against anyone else for any other
communicable disease
we don't have in statute where you have
to show
those those types of uh affidavits that
any other questions follow-up
yep you can follow up um is there
um is there a is there even a more
general do you feel there's a natural
right to endanger other people
i feel that people
have the right to protect themselves as
they see fit and because you may differ
what you think may be endangering on the
other hand someone else may feel that
what you're enforcing is endangering
them also
thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question what do you mean that
shoot your last statement i'm so sorry
now i got too flustered how was that in
um
that that we would be endangering
someone that had not gotten a vaccine
how was that
thank you for the question
representative chase i can just talk
from personal experience
i can tell you with certainty
that my sister-in-law in may of 2021
after receiving the vaccination
died of a massive heart attack within 48
hours
i can tell you that there have been
studies done
where
17 people have received vaccinations and
of the 17 2 have developed bell's policy
okay there are definite side effects and
definite repercussions from this
vaccination and to force somebody to
take something when we do not know what
it is
because you are also putting those
people should have the choice it is
bodily integrity if
you want to ha i don't
begrudge anyone from taking a
vaccination or an immunization
if they feel that is in the best
interest of their health
but for others who may have compromised
immune systems or other issues
that would be detrimental to the health
as we saw with my sister-in-law
so
um
you know
this
us you know
there is
ways to protect yourself you are wearing
a
mask
because you feel that will help protect
you
from everyone else
and that is your choice and it is a
choice
that has afforded us under the
constitution
representative langley
thank you mr chair for taking my
question and thank you representative
i'm truly sorry for the loss of your
sister-in-law
could i ask you on line number eight
line eight
are you use the language because the
person refuses to use a medical device
how exactly do you define medical device
uh thank you representative langley for
that
question
a medical device could be anything that
a person is forced to use that would
inhibit their health
for some
it could be an n95 mask or something to
that effect
but what happens is when we do a
one-size-fits-all we don't take into
account the mental anguish that we are
forcing on others that for one reason or
another
for psychological reasons
by
wearing a medical device would cause
them extreme harm
representative lorenzo
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question i'm i'm really sorry
now um you mentioned um
medical devices or we talk about medical
devices such as n95 mask i do believe
that
many of us are wearing the mask to
prevent others from getting sick that's
just a clarification thank you
is that that a question
or
would you believe that some of us are
wearing masks because we want to prevent
spreading infection in the in the event
that we do have the virus
thank you for the question
representative lorenzo um i do believe
representative kennedy
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
for taking my question um you have
quoted a few studies would you mind
sharing those with the committee at a at
a later time like through email
i
will look into that a little further and
see what i can get you yeah well
they were told to me
i don't know if the study is actually
public
it was through something in our county
representative smith did you have a
question well just to follow up um do
you mean that your your county medical
officer shared those with you and if so
could you tell me what county because
then we could contact them
uh representatives thank you for the
question representative smith it was
conveyed to another representative
and told to me
but it was in belknap county
representative chase thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
i think we got off track here this is
relative to equal access to places in
public economic accommodations
regardless of vaccine status
could you just i
get back on or all of us on track as to
you're talking about what if we wanted
to go to
um
a concert and they asked you to show
your
your vaccine card and you don't have one
because you're not
you didn't get vaccinated this is what
the bill is about correct it's not about
the choice of having a vaccine or i'm
very sorry again about your
sister-in-law and maybe the 17 people
that had bell's palsy but when you're
thinking of the millions of people and
trying to save lives
i just would like to get back on track
with that uh well thank you for the
question representative chase um yes it
is about vaccine status and it is about
going to public places and concerts
but we have to understand
that we have right to privacy of our
medical information and asking someone
to show their medical vaccination status
is a and
is a violation of private
medical information you should not have
to be
we have hipaa laws for certain reasons
but yet we're making an exception for
vaccination status for a specific
disease
other
i guess the question i have
you
addressing specifically public
accommodations
thank you representative gordon and yes
i am specifically addressing at equal
access to pump public accommodations it
is a civil right and no one should be
discriminated against for any reason
we just heard a bill although
it was didn't deal with directly with
vaccination status but immunization
status
which was more comprehensive in terms of
and
is there a reason why you picked public
accommodation as opposed to making it
broader
there is a reason because i had
constituents and this is just a
duplicate of my bill that i introduced
last year that never received a vote um
due to the uh
not finishing the voting on the in
session
and it came about because i had
constituents
that had gone to
places of public accommodation for over
20 years and were then denied access
for refusal to wear a medical device or
to show a vaccination status
that was
they then could not get their groceries
from their local store
that it affected them
and their family and that affects their
health
and uh i'm going to plead ignorance here
in terms of i'm sure somewhere in
the law
the
public accommodation is defined
it is
yeah and and
i suspect that that is
when we think generally of public
accommodation we think of
hotels motels and restaurants but
i suspect it's defined more broadly than
that is that correct in chapter two
under the rsa
i believe is definitions
and you're in intending it to be more
as you mentioned grocery stores you're
tending it to be more broadly
construed than simply restaurants or
or
seeing none thank you for your testimony
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee again my name is kathy
bizarro-thundberg executive vice
president new hampshire hospital
association representing all 26 acute
care hospitals and all specialty
hospitals in our state
the new hampshire hospital association
is opposed to house bill 1490 fm
the bill before you would provide that
an individual shall be not be denied
access to places of public accommodation
placed on vaccination status ordered the
decision not to use a medical device
we do not believe it's appropriate to
include vaccination status as a
protected class under the state
commission for human rights
this committee just heard a similar bill
house bill 1260 as well as a bill last
week house bill 1519 which we also
testified in opposition
this bill as well other this bill as
well as other bills before this
committee attempts to insert additional
classes into the statute that protects
individuals from discrimination it's our
position that adding these additional
classes is not appropriate and not in
not the intention of our
anti-discrimination laws
we believe all these bills are focused
on without explicitly stating so an
attempt to insert vague language into
statute against covert 19 vaccine or
other public health measure measures as
such as mass
we're also concerned that the term
medical device in this bill is vague and
misleading especially if the intent is
really focused on masks
the result of all these bills will just
lead to lawsuits and other further
confusion among employers employee
employees and patrons of public
establishments
it's our position that employers in any
business open to the public have a right
to determine what is best for their
employees their clients their patients
and or their patrons
requiring vaccinations of healthcare
workers from communicable disease is not
new to hospitals as i mentioned earlier
they have required vaccination against
several communicable and deadly diseases
such as mumps measles rubella
chickenpox diphtheria tetanus pertussis
and influenza as a condition of
employment with the same type of medical
and religious exemptions allowed for
covert 19 vaccines
we believe requiring vaccinations is
absolutely the right thing to do for the
health and safety of our patients our
staff and the citizens of new hampshire
the vast majority of hospital staff have
been vaccinated against cover 19 or have
received exemptions and we've heard from
many many health care workers who
support the vaccine requirement to
protect the health of themselves as well
as their patients
i just want to also add to my testimony
i just wanted to clarify one thing that
the sponsor of the bill mentioned
regarding hipaa health insurance
portability and accountability act it is
not applied correctly by the sponsor
hipaa requires covered entities such as
hospitals and other health care
providers to protect information that
they have received it is it does not
apply to individuals who were asked to
share their information so i just want
to make sure that that was clarified
in conclusion we are opposed to house
bill 1490 fn and we urge this committee
to find this bill in expedient to
legislate thank you for the opportunity
to present our testimony
are there questions
yes representative simpson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
if this were if this bill were to go
into effect i'm trying to get my head
around
the violation of rights of those who are
physically disabled in some way that
they can't be vaccinated or are so
immunocompromised that the antibodies do
not build enough
um and i wondered if you
if your members in the hospital
association or for you or if you have
talked through
that um
that right
we understand that there are individuals
that just cannot um have the vaccine for
a variety of reasons because they're
immunocompromised or they may be
allergic to one or more of the
ingredients in the vaccine that's why
there are other mitigation measures that
are in place such as mass
and social distancing washing hands
staying home when you're sick
so
vaccine is just one of the many tools
that can be used from a public health
perspective to support those who cannot
other questions representative sylvia
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
is it the new hampshire
hospital association's position that
patients
should be vaccinated before getting
treatment
no
that is not what we're saying
we will treat any patient that comes
into our hospitals who are in need
representative sylvia
so you're opposing this
measure
it would seem
that you
have some desire to discriminate against
somebody we believe that any uh
location whether it's public
accommodation or any other location that
requires access to someone's vaccination
status or requires that a mask be worn
that they should be allowed to ask for
those accommodations to be put into
place for those individuals who want to
partake
one more follow-up
so you you testified that you want to
protect your workers
but you also testified that your workers
are
almost 100 percent vaccinated
can you clarify
the danger that
a person poses
if they don't even present to have
any symptoms of the disease well as i
mentioned one of the other mitigating
factors is also mask wearing and so
hospitals do require anyone entering a
hospital setting to wear a mask and so
it is their right to be able to ask for
see none thank you for your testimony
today
is it
roseanne or rossann chester
thanks
thank you
i'm coming today in um
in support of this bill
i am a i am a um living breathing
um vaccine injured individual not from
the covet 19 vaccine i develop bell's
palsy after a flu shot seven years ago
um i'd had the flu shot numerous times
before
never had a problem
um and
i um
but myself and seven of my co-workers
all develop bell's palsy that year
i'm one of the lucky ones i have a
slight droop to the left side but other
than that i have no um
lasting
results
this bill if if not passed does
discriminate against people like me
the cdc has now said that cloth masks
don't do anything to protect you
um
but if you want to wear masks because
you feel you're more protected or you
feel you more you're more than
protecting you're protecting me more i'm
okay with that
uh with regards to the vaccine itself i
cannot take this vaccine because to date
they they have not provided every single
ingredient
we don't know exactly what caused my
vaccine injury but i am not willing to
make that choice to take a vaccine and
end up a statistic
i also have a very close friend
um whose son died over the weekend
from
i don't know if it'll be identified as a
vaccine injury but he had his
vaccine booster on friday he died on
saturday
it was following a flight to florida so
i don't know if there was a combination
all i'm saying folks is that this
vaccine is and and the cdc and num
numerous other people have now come out
and said the vaccine will not prevent us
you or me
from getting covet 19. it will lessen
the the um
lessen the symptoms i've had coven 19.
um fortunately i did not have severe
symptoms i don't feel that i should that
i should be discriminated against
because
i can't take this vaccine
and i won't take this vaccine
and it's getting to the point that
i'm starting to feel as though i need
the protection from the state of new
hampshire because
i have been denied i am now covered
retired i've been denied
my religious and my
medical exemptions
from a
company in massachusetts in health care
so at this point i support this bill
because i feel
we the people of new hampshire need to
be able to
um not be discriminated events against
thank you
thank you so much for uh for coming
um
i i've listened carefully to
some serious charges that you laid out
and and realize how
complicated all of this is for all of us
what
what interests me is that this
particular bill refers only to places of
public accommodation
and
yet all of your concerns seem to
relate to all kinds of situations but
not necessarily public accommodations so
i'm wondering what attracted you to
this narrow
legislation rather than for example the
bill we heard
earlier today
i would have liked to have been here for
the bill you heard earlier i was in
another session ah
um
so legitimate problems we're all having
these legitimate problems um with
regards yes this is a much more narrow
um the other one is a much broader was a
much broader um
i
made a choice
um and
and
with regards to public accommodations
that is exactly my point is i have been
my doctor
who is a member of the new hampshire
hospital association
will not
provide me with an exemption for this
vaccine because she is too afraid to
lose her license
that is not acceptable and the fact that
new hampshire hospital association and
and all these other people come here
oppose these kind of bills is not okay
the money that they are making
the money that they are making off the
backs of us is not okay
and it needs to be recognized and it
needs to be identified we you can go to
the verse report and you can see now
almost a thousand people
no
more than a thousand people are vaccine
injured from this covet 19
shot in new hampshire more than a
that alone says it's time it's time to
start discriminating against the people
that either don't want to take the
vaccine or like me
i can't
and the masks
putting masks on children
and forcing them in a public
in a public place to wear a mask to
eight to ten hours a day there are tons
of studies regarding
um issues with that and reactive
attachment disorder when did we lose
sight of the emotional
thank you very much i'm sorry
mr chair if i could ask that you
give us the citations for those studies
that you've quoted because um
that would be very very for the reactive
attachment disorder that was one you
also talked about uh
number
one where you refer to the numbers of
people who had vaccine uh
uh reactions that's the verse report
it's a it's a public
um but i will get you that information
i'll email it to you folks i i really
appreciate it thanks thank you very much
thank you
any other questions representative
horrigan
um yes thank you one of the pieces of
evidence you cited in your testimony was
that something had happened to you in
massachusetts at a healthcare facility
of some sort and
presumably you want to change our laws
so the protections so
they're more protective than in
what they have in massachusetts so
without
giving away any like
sensitive details what could you flesh
out that anecdote just a little bit more
i mean you did give it a time recently
and a place massachusetts so that's
better than a lot of the anecdotes we
hear in this committee but you want to
flesh it out a little bit just
you know just serve a few a few
salient details just to make it more
convincing thanks i was a private
non-profit i worked for a private
nonprofit insurance company
that dealt only with medicare and
medicaid patients
so they have
they receive a lot of money from the
federal government with regards to the
covert 19 max
bandit mandate back
covet 19 vaccine mandate
um
and uh
this so that that's the
is does that give you enough information
i was a new hampshire resident but
working in massachusetts oh so this is
uh
so you work for a company in mass
massachusetts and
you're discriminated against there in
the workplace is that what it is
well they refused my medical and
um religious exemptions because they
they said that um i couldn't get a note
from my doctor
that i was met and i gave them the
information that i was vaccine injured
okay thanks sir representative lorenzo
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question hi could you talk
more about um
the incident of you getting bell's palsy
and then
i think you said seven of your other
co-workers um
[Music]
i can talk more about it yeah okay so um
it was working uh again a private
non-profit in massachusetts um
we have a
it's required we work with um like i
said said um in massachusetts they're
called dual eligible so they're um
they're on medicare and medicaid so
they're either
disabled adults or elderly low-income
and
one of the things that i did was i was a
social worker that went into their homes
and worked with them
we'd it's a requirement to have the flu
shot or to have an exemption
um i'd always had my flu shot with them
i'd worked for them for a number of
years uh for whatever reason that year
um my and there were a hundred of us on
there were 100 of us
um during that
rollout of the flu that the flu shot
that developed belt and out of the
hundred seven of us developed bell's
palsy of all different and it was within
24 hours of having that flu shot
um
but
i was also completely aware that that
was a net that that was a potential
consequence and not typically
uh it's always there's a potential for a
side effect but it's not
a typical side effect and like i said to
this day we don't know why
out of the seven of us that develop
bell's palsy
only two had never had a flu shot before
so there were five of us that had had
flu shots for years and years and years
and for whatever reason that year we
developed bell's palsy
may i follow up
thank you um so were there any legal
ramifications like a class action suit
or anything like that amongst the folks
who were
you know affected by
the flu shot
i i can only speak for myself there was
no class action um or there was no
litigation or action um against my
employer from me because i was
completely educated and i knew that that
was a potential consequence
um
i also um
i knew that like so i was fully informed
and i took the flu shot and um and i'd
had the and i've had the flu shot since
knowing that that is a potential side
effect for me um
but i've chosen
to i've made that choice to take the flu
shot because it was a
isolated incident and i just am very
careful on
with regards to what's in the flu shots
now so in if they're if uh for instance
um my doctor has identified i have an
allergy to magnesium
most
um vaccinations
do have magnesium in them
um so it depends on the type of
magnesium the amount of the compound
things like that so as long as they give
me that information then i can make an
educated decision on whether or not
i will take that vaccine or not the
problem with the kova 19 vaccine is they
have not yet given us us that
information
thank you very much
any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
just a very brief
yes just a very brief uh note
um about discrimination and how it
occurs at sort of an illustrated point
um
from my experience in the workplace or
in the place of public accommodation
the way it becomes known that a person
is vaccinated or not
is
and i've never seen this before in years
past
with other vaccines but in this vaccine
in particular
is that people for the last two years
since the vaccine is rolled out
in the workplace or in a place of public
accommodation announce
that they are vaccinated
um
and then they go around say there's a
group
each one announces that they had the
vaccine when they had the vaccine how
much they've been vaccinated
and then the person who is not chosen to
have a vaccine
is
has no protection against
their privacy because
they can only remain silent
or say that they have they don't want to
disclose it
it's obvious
that they
have not been vaccinated
and so this is how it's happening
i in my experience
anecdotally
talking to other people in workplaces or
other places of public accommodation
it's now become
uh the the social pressure is enormous
to
disclose and talk about
how you've been vaccinated and so it's
your silence is no uh guarantee
uh of your privacy
and that is the only point i wanted to
questions
um represent oregon did you have a
question um yes well there's um
i assume you're not too
few motives to them but
obviously your co-workers are uh
probably very concerned about
contracting a respiratory virus that has
killed over 800 000 people yes okay oh
um
well do you
okay sorry thank you thank you um so do
you feel that like the fear of
a co-worker spreading a respiratory
virus to you is that a
legitimate concern for your co-workers
to be expressing are you saying they
should not be expressing that
thank you for your question
representative horrigan
no i'm not making a judgment about
why
or if it's appropriate
but similar to other types of
discrimination
such as gender
identity
and
you know physical or mental disability
you
it is um it's just uh you can't remain
silent and
you are just therefore discriminated
against after trying to be remain silent
and try to keep your vaccination status
private
it's similar to
say in a workplace or a place of public
accommodation when somebody says
you know i'm not gay
are you gay no i'm not gay are you gay
and then it becomes an issue
where well you did not disclose that
you're
not gay
so
we can infer
that you are indeed gay
and then that is when discrimination
happens so and that is what i've seen
from
in the workplace or in places of even
public accommodation this is happening
in public meetings
and people go around and make the
disclosure because there's so much
pressure social pressure to do so and
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
good morning again
my name is ani malachi i'm the executive
director of the human rights commission
i am providing informational testimony
this morning on hb 1490
as uh the commission is not taking a
position on this bill
i think one of the questions that i
would like to address
was relative to public accommodation and
so to assist with that i will read from
our statute it won't take too long
what we specify as a public okay i was
just about to say good grief i had it
pulled up and ready to go and then it
got disappeared um so public places of
public accommodation includes any inn
tavern or hotel
whether conducted for entertainment the
housing or lodging of transient guests
or for the benefit use or accommodations
of those seeking health recreational
rest any restaurant eating house public
conveyance on land or water
bath house barber shop theater
golf course sports arena health care
provider and music or other public hall
store or other establishment which
caters or offers its services or
facilities or goods to the general
public
public accommodation shall not include
any institution or club which is in its
nature distinctly uh private
so
that is the definition of public
accommodation
and
um
let's see and i have one other note here
further in the pro
the proposed piece of legislation
relative to
medical devices
um
the fda's definition and this is just
let's see so
and i know there was some conversation
um
about
medical treatments and refusal
treatments and although the right to
refuse a medical treatment is fundament
is a fundamental right recognized by the
united states supreme court
the commission sees that medical device
in this particular language of this bill
is somewhat vague and it can apply to
and this is the fda's definition of
medical device
medical devices range from simple tongue
depressors and bed pans to complex
programmable pacemakers closed loop
artificial pancreas systems and
blood glucose monitors etc
so with that
understanding it it makes it a bit vague
and we would hope if this were to pass
it there would be some clarification on
medical device and finally having both
elements so including the vaccination
status being added and
refusal of a medical device it does make
it could potentially make it a bit more
challenging for a business to provide a
reasonable accommodation so an example
of that would be
if they
required you to wear a medical device
but you couldn't because of a health
condition of some sort or you just
didn't want to the business could do
some form of reasonable accommodation
and we saw some of that
during the pandemic where they could
meet the person outside or maybe they
could wear a face shield versus a mask
and so if both of these elements are in
here then it makes it a bit more
challenging for the business to look for
a reasonable accommodation to
if they are if they are requiring a mask
or some other medical device it makes it
a more challenging for them to to work
around that so as not to be
discriminatory
towards someone if this element passes
so thank you with that i end my
testimony and i'm available for
questions
thank you mr chair thank you very much
that's very helpful
um
i'm sure you didn't read absolutely
every word in that definition of public
accommodation and for that i thank you
um but i want to inquire as to whether
um
in that definition
you see um
that either a public institution of
higher
uh learning or a private institution of
higher learning would be included as a
public accommodation
um thank you very much for the question
at this time it is not
but i will also reserve the opportunity
to further scrutinize and email you back
if that is not the correct answer
but i do believe places of education are
thank you very much and thank you for
being so careful about
about checking your own facts we really
other
questions i have a question
yes
this applies to
access to public accommodations
so the question is in the case of an
employer
so an employer who operates
this is the access
applied to the people who are customers
or ca would this apply to the employer
being able to
require its employees to wear mass
so thank you very very much for the
question um if i understand correctly
you're asking if if this were to pass
does it relate to the employees
and
the uh the customers and the public okay
so thank you very much for the for
assisting you with the clarification
based on the way this is written because
it's focused on public accommodation
only it is public-facing meaning
customers of that particular business if
it were in employment if it was if
employment was added here then this
would speak to the employees and staff
thank you
other questions
representative lorenzo thank you mr
claire and thank you for taking my
question um
so when we're talking about medical
devices would this be a good example of
perhaps um
not
a public accommodation
for instance a restaurant would not be
able to
um
allow a reasonable accommodation to a
person who wants to visit the restaurant
wants to eat there
and let's say that the restaurant has
like one of those open grills
and
envision the
customer
wearing using an oxygen tank
so if they
were
not allowed to eat in the establishment
uh because of the inherent danger of
oxygen with an open flame would that and
would that not be a violation of this
bill if it were to pass
um thank you very much representative
lorenzo for the question um i am going
to take a little stab at that however
it's very difficult
because
subjective questions or
broad hypotheticals make a moving their
moving target right so in the
investigative process we would ask all
of these different questions so if the
person were to file a charge saying i
went to this restaurant i have an oxygen
tank and i went to open flame and they
wouldn't seat me at all
then we would potentially take that as a
charge
verifying that they went to the
restaurant and and some other
information making sure that it meets
the minimum standard to walk into the
door upon further scrutiny once we
looked at it
if they did not offer another seat so if
it is by law whether it's a new
hampshire statute or a federal statute
that says you cannot use an oxygen tank
near an open flame then we would look at
were there other places uh
adjacent to the area that the person
could sit now an accommodation doesn't
necessarily afford you the exact same
experience as someone else but it does
allow you to be in the restaurant be
served and have the food so
would the an accommodation in this
scenario could potentially be a booth
somewhere else but still enjoying the
food or something nearby so that they
could witness what everyone else is
witnessing if it was
if it's illegal for that person by new
hampshire law or federal law or a
combination thereof to be sitting next
to an open flame now the person doesn't
have to accept this accommodation and
the person could leave and the person
could certainly come and file a charge
with us because they felt they were
discriminated against it is their right
to do so and then once we look at the um
the parameters and look at the
specificity of exactly what happened
then we would make a determination of
probable cause through investigation or
no probable cause and a no probable
cause finding in this particular example
would say
yes you were not able to sit next to the
open flame however the rest based on
whatever the law is because we would
cite that in the investigation or in the
summary of that
however the restaurant did provide a
reasonable accommodation to allow you to
sit near adjacent somewhere close so
that the
the experience was somewhat the same
obviously it's not what the person
wanted but it was an accommodation so
long answer to short question um and
it's hard because some of these things
are moving targets because without all
of the
specifics it's it's challenging so
with that said
the business would hopefully be able to
provide a reasonable accommodation so if
the city of concord had a mass mandate
and
the business is following
that um
based on this then they would want they
should be able to
provide or they would want to provide
a reasonable accommodation for that
person who either cannot which if you
cannot wear one
based on medical reasons there's already
an exemption for that so there could be
disability involved
so there's already an exemption for that
if you choose not then
the business could say well let's forget
the concord mask mandate but let's say
the business says
either all people wear a mask or no
people wear a mask then maybe that's the
reasonable accommodation to not run
afoul of this of hb
1490 if it were to pass
thank you for taking my question thank
you mr chair
just so
i just want to clarify and i understand
exactly what you're saying about the
oxygen in an open flame and it's not we
don't want you here it's
we're going to accommodate you in
another area
now this bill is saying relative to
equal access if
so
couldn't
hypothetically someone not vaccinated
still be able to have access but yet
have to be maybe in a different area
like we've been doing with the you know
no mask area or novak's area so that
you're you're trying to compromise and
be able to have everybody have the same
experience yet you might not be able to
be right up front in a venue you have to
be in a different area so that everybody
is held safe would that be
in your opinion
not holding you to it something that
might be able to work this out so that
everyone's allowed to still enjoy
life
that is an excellent question and i
thank you for it um you know one of the
things that i don't do at the commission
is just go with my opinion
if i had that question that you just
asked and in my mind i think well maybe
this is the answer if the answer that
you proposed
moving people to a different section to
allow what i would then do with that is
immediately go to my client services
representative that works at the
attorney general's office as it is their
responsibility to interpret the law so
what they would do is we would run maybe
a scenario or two to allow us to think
through what the possibilities are
really and what we also do is is look at
what is the definition of reasonable
accommodation what are the precedents
that have happened previously with
rulings um and interpretation of that
particular portion of our statute in the
past and so we look for patterns in
practice
and when we do that then we're able to
apply all of that to this one individual
situation to then recognize if they do
have a charge
and they were discriminated against or
that they do not have a charge and maybe
putting them in a separate section was a
reasonable accommodation although it
wasn't what they initially wanted so i
would um
i would dare not venture into the land
of curiosity there
and would respectfully like to if that
were a situation would absolutely and i
hope you feel confident in in that
that we immediately would ask the
attorney general's office uh to make
sure because it is not our job my job or
the job of the commission to make law
we enforce what the legislature has put
forward and if there are any questions
any doubt hesitancy curiosity
uncertainty can we push it here or what
do we need to do we will go to the
it's me representative sylvia
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
this is a little bit more broad of a
question um
in terms of
the the work that you do
versus if somebody is discriminated
against feel they're discriminated
against do they have the opportunity to
go straight to the court and and file a
suit for
some sort of tortious interference or
something in that nature
um thank you very much for the question
um the way the statute is written
relative to public employment excuse me
employment
public accommodation and housing
you must come to the commission and you
file your initial charge there
should the complainant want to withdraw
that charge and move it to court they
have the opportunity to do so and
there's a process in our statute in our
rules that specifies what that process
is however in education which was added
to our statute as of 2019 a person has
what we would call a true choice of
forum meaning they can file with the
with the commission they may go to the
attorney general's office and file a
charge and that would more than likely
if it's discriminatory behavior that
they're alleging that would be under the
civil rights unit so they could file a
charge with the attorney general's
office or they may take it directly to
court that is up to
the uh determination or the decision of
the complainant if they would choose to
do that
thank you your depth of knowledge in
this area is
very
amazing thank you
i'm making diamonds over here so
[Laughter]
any other
questions representative horrigan do you
have a question um thank you you
provided an explanation what a medical
device is um but it where's the
dividing life the israel between
medical devices and then you know
protective equipment like helmets or for
example where i used to work at the
racetrack in certain areas ear
protectors were required and
in the pits you would have to wear even
more than just your protectors but so is
there a
is there a is there a line and is it a
fuzzy one or
a not so fuzzy one thanks
thank you very much representative
horgan for the question
so the definition that i provided was me
reading from the fda's website as to
what they consider a medical device
and if this met legislation were to
become law then we would look at that
understand what that means i mean
hopefully there would be some additional
clarification so that we had
understanding of what we're looking at
so that if a charge is filed we have
information within the statute to
in in the definition section certainly
to make that determination however if
that were not afforded to us
medical device versus personal
protective equipment we would then as
i've stated before go to the attorney
general's office and look through
who who are the leading
uh folks organizations that would make
that determination would it be the fda
if they are the regulatory body then we
would look to them we would talk to the
attorney general's office and then we
would work on what that definition would
be and if there are additional statutory
changes that would need to take place to
include said definition then we would do
whatever the process would be to make
that
possible if it means just adding it into
our rules through a rules change we
could certainly do that if it meant that
we needed to do something in a statutory
body a statutory manner we would
certainly seek out one of the
professionals to assist us with that
process
great thanks
absolutely
are there any other questions
i just have one brief question and that
is it this
in terms of the statute and the way it's
interpreted it
it talks about having equal access to
places of public accommodation
so that access means i'm presuming
physical access to the place and not
necessarily access to the services that
they provide is that correct
that is a really good question i i would
want to circle back to
to look at um
to give you a very specific answer
because it's it it feels like the
chicken or the egg you know if you don't
have access to the place then you don't
have access to the service um and so
having a reasonable accommodation
just in the example that
representative de lorenzo and i were
discussing
that individual with the oxygen oxygen
tank would still have equal access to
the restaurant
but they would not have the same level
of access to the area with the open
flame
so
i would want to
look at that a little more closely to
give you a more specific answer
based on
what's written here
i don't i don't want to
i don't want to shoot in the dark on
that one well if i can just follow up
the the issue is this and we've heard
from the hospital association
it provides equal access
so
you could
have access to
the hospital
but does that give you the right to
have the services the hospital provides
so if a doctor said i don't want to
provide service
to
someone
does this
that is a good question because i i
would really want to look at
more specifically
the access to an accommodation
so when you're looking at a store
you want to have access to get into that
store
once you're in the store then
the services that are rendered would be
you being able to purchase whatever the
things are in the store unless there are
certain regulations meaning you know if
they're cigarettes you can't you know
purchase those unless you're a certain
age if there are guns you can't purchase
those at a certain age or other
materials that have specific either
state or federal restrictions so to be
very specific on that answer
again i would want to make sure if it
access to the service and
i would have to
call on my my paralegal back here uh
potentially and i could circle back and
give you an answer if there's someone
else i could come back up and answer
that question more specifically um but
um
yeah i'd wanted i'd want to do that i
don't wanna i don't wanna stab it in the
dark on that
thank you any other questions
sigmund thank you for your testimony
thank you
victoria
need to turn on your microphone please
oh the red button is on okay
uh my name is victoria gullah i live in
spafford
uh i wasn't here earlier because i had
to drop my son off at school and it's
about an hour away
so that's why i chose this bill to come
today
for public access but i've been affected
i have lung damage from very limited
mask wearing
last
more than a year ago now at the
beginning of all this
and i also have a son with tourette
syndrome which
most people think of tourette's as
something where people involuntarily
spout out words or particularly bad
words but for my son it's a tick
disorder
and he um he's he's gonna be
nine on one next wednesday
and he goes through different ticks
and
one that he's really into now is chewing
so
expensive beautiful coats and sweaters
he chews
his hands he chews he chews them raw
one of the things that makes a tick
disorder worse
is anxiety
and
if you go through something like a cold
we rub our noses i see lots of people
kind of ruining the whole purpose of
their their mask or their respirator
because they're touching them all the
time
so
you tend to touch your face more when
you're wearing a mask and germs do get
through them
and now you've touched it and now you're
touching so now you're actually taking
your hands and spreading your germs
well when you get a cold you're wiping
your nose and when you're an
eight-year-old little boy or a
six-year-old boy
you can't really help doing that and the
more you do these things when you have a
tick disorder that becomes your new tick
so he's had different tics where
he might shake his hands like this he
jump up and down and they come with
excitement anxiety christmas lots of
jumping we went to the circus he almost
killed me jumping on me
um
it's
this is all part of a tick disorder it's
also he has um it's almost like an
oppositional defiance thing where you
say marco don't do that
don't touch that and he touches it
immediately he can't help it it's that's
part of the tick disorder
and
um
you know it's really fun having a kid
who can't keep his hands out of his
mouth so when he gets a cold and he's
rubbing his nose that's where the tick
goes so if he used to be
doing this with his arms and he gets a
cold now his hand is here and he's
rubbing his nose he's chewing
um
he's in my car like leaning on the side
of the car
with his nose on it
so when you put a mask
on top of that
it creates that feeling
and now he wants to touch his face
was he doing this in the summer no
because
he doesn't have colds in the summer
you're not wearing a collar around your
mouth you're not wearing a coat that you
zip up like this you're not wearing a
balaclava to ski that's on your face
so
bringing this child out in public i've
never put a mask on him and i won't put
a mask on him
it increases the anxiety it increases
the disorder
and we work very hard with him and he's
a bit young to do the cognitive
behavioral therapy like i'll say okay
take your hand down try to tap your leg
do this instead but he's chewing his
hands he's chewed his hands raw
like
practically bleeding
as part of this tick disorder
and he's in a homeschool pod
because he's denied his public education
in new hampshire
at a state charter school
the school denied
pushed me off pushed me off
and as the previous woman testified
his pediatric neurologist at dartmouth
in your network
is too afraid
i'm sorry
no no this is necessary
this is necessary
because these hospitals are leading the
discrimination
and they are leading
improper care their leading
disinformation
a mask
where is it that one does nothing
you talk to any industrial hygienist
that mask does nothing he's got it goes
right out the sides so these ladies on
each side of him they're getting a plume
of his aerosols
85 to 95 percent of covid is distributed
in aerosols it comes through
your bottom end in the toilet so you go
into the bathroom with your mask on
and you go into a toilet plume that is a
thing look it up toilet plume
and you're going into the aerosols that
came through your gi tract
and now you have it stuck to your mask
and now you're going to inhale that
and it's going to come through your mask
or it gets trapped in your mask
so these hospital associations they need
to be called out they're not treating
people properly and they're lying
about masks you you can testify but you
don't need to make it personal that's no
it is very personal
my lungs have been injured by these
masks
and like i say i'm a stay-at-home mom
i didn't have to wear them often i
happened to have a little seasonal
allergy a little cold when the whole
cove had started
so
you know wear my stupid mask i had some
a box of masks at home from when my
daughter over here was an infant and i
had a bad cold
and
you see people you know i lived in new
york city many years i'm from new
hampshire i'm a native
and you see people when they're sick
wearing them on the subway and
everything your reaction on the subway
is to lift up your scarf
and um you know you hold the pole on the
subway with a glove
you are pushed in that subway in
manhattan
and you feel you smell people's bad
breath all right that's how crowded the
subway is so you're like this
all right
and it doesn't do anything you feel that
you're doing something you're not doing
anything you all have gaps all of you
have gaps if you can take your hair
take your hair pull it out of your head
can you push it down between your nose
and your face if you can you are not
protected
and you're not protecting other people
now
this is where this goes with public
accommodation
places are forcing you to wear these
things that provide
no protection and people are being lied
to
and they're being lied to
by the hospitals
the hospitals are not industrial
hygienists
they hire them to teach their surgeons
how to properly use a mask do you know
that surgeons are told
when they're wearing a procedure mask
not to turn their head when they clear
their throat or have to do a little
cough so if you're doing surgery
you don't turn why because if you turn
the plume comes out the side
all right
so this is what this hospital
association person should know
and i can't get a letter from a
pediatric neurologist who himself i
think actually has tourette's because he
was a little
i could see him kind of control his and
he was a lovely man he was so
lovely we met with two different
pediatric neurologists one retired in
august before all the mandates you
wonder about that
why would he retire when
children need psychiatric help
when they're
being
you know
when the hospitals here overflowing
that's an issue in new hampshire we read
about that on the front pages you're all
well aware why would a pediatric
neurologist at dartmouth
why would he retire in august before the
vaccination mandates why think about it
and the other one lovely i mean lovely
people spent so much time with us giving
us kind of help and guidance but still
says why doesn't he try wearing the mask
what makes it worse
i'm his mother i'm with him all the time
i'm with this child all the time i know
all right
and he can't go to school in new
hampshire at a public charter school
because these people put us off oh you
have to do a 401 do this do with that
and you're making all these calls you go
to the district and they're like oh well
uh that's not a learning disability it's
a physical disability if i do this that
oh you have to have a meeting with all
these people well i can't wear a mask at
your meeting they won't meet with me
well you can't do this can you do a zoom
meeting no you don't hear back so forget
them
now they're sending emails telling lying
saying that children need to be
vaccinated in the school
so that they can help spread stop spread
the disease the vaccination does not
stop the spread in fact it promotes the
spread
why don't you look at your data and see
that every time a vaccination rolls out
that age group cova cases spike do you
know why because the vaccine suppresses
your cd8 and cd4 and natural killer
cells so for two to three weeks after
your vaccination and booster you are
particularly susceptible to getting what
covid
and
you know we've heard about the vaccine
injuries my son has tourette's it might
be from one of the vaccines i only know
now that tourette's and tic disorders
are one of the many disorders that can
happen after
childhood vaccinations and my son i
spaced them too i thought oh you know
you get nervous as a mom right
and you hear all this stuff and you know
that
autism is linked even if the cdc tries
to lie about that and they literally
shredded the data on that
they're full of lies they all are
and it's inappropriate it's not
inappropriate it must be said it must be
said if you could just focus your
testimony on the legislation itself yes
so all of these things
where this vaccination that they're
requiring
for public accommodation can you go to
crotchet mountain ski area on when it's
five below zero
can you go inside and get hot chocolate
no you cannot you need a vaccination
pass to do that they're supposed to have
a little window where you can go up
is the window open no because they don't
have enough employees why because they
require vaccination to be employed there
i was offered i spent years coaching ski
racing well two sorry two years coaching
ski racing that's in years i grew up ski
raising i coached two years at watch i
spent 17 years
officiating ski racing in new hampshire
did i i was going to get back into it i
had thyroid cancer when i was pregnant i
baby c-section all this stuff right
before ski season so i took a couple
years off from officiating after 17
years
i really wanted to get back into it last
year who would have to be the mask
police last year
me as the official no i'm not gonna be
masked police
my lungs are wrecked from masks
would i do that no i've been at crotch i
did sign my son up this year we're
ignoring the stupid mask thing in the
inside but i can't go in the lodge and
get a hot chocolate for my child
that's discrimination
it's discrimination against the healthy
my vitamin d level is 70 nanograms per
milliliter
i'm pretty much immune to
at least delta and the in the beta and
the alpha
cova disease
omicron kind of gets everyone i guess
if you ever heard that do you hear why
aren't these hospitals associations
telling everybody to get their vitamin d
levels up
they're not i have 20 something emails
from dartmouth hitchcock yeah if you can
again just
this is this is part of the public
accommodation they are not they are
discriminating against healthy people
if you get the vaccine after you've had
covet you ruin your natural immunity
and it's dangerous
to your immune system
you will damage your immune system and
make your immune system susceptible to
other things um all kinds of immuno
they're still finding out because they
didn't allow these vaccines to get
tested still under emergency use you go
oh it's approved
co-minardis approved is that available
here it is not
you cannot get the fda approved vaccine
so you
by these businesses through their
coveted fascism working with different
administrations
to get their
vax pass through so that you can get
into the chinese social credit system
which is what it is it's not really
about a vaccine
no it needs to be sad
it needs to be said ms gullah you just
need to stick to the legislation you're
going this way the legislation
this is protecting this is a stepping
stone to protect the people of new
hampshire
from getting put into
a system which will
take all of your information and it
won't just be used for vaccination it's
used for banking it's used for credit
scores it is used for everything you're
shaking your head no you're wrong
he's shaking his head
i can address this just
please ms this is just we just want you
to provide your testimony this is my
testimony my testimony is that this bill
is a step to protect people it's
protecting healthy people
from this poisonous vaccine okay
and it is protecting people from masks
they don't
no
there is not one you can ask me a
question there are no studies
that show they work representative
horgan
i think you could refrain as well
you didn't i have been escorted
is my testimony yes i know and you asked
for five to eight minutes and we're
getting close to 15 now so
if you could just sort of wrap up and uh
your conclusion it would be appreciated
all right thank you
i got bacterial pneumonia from wearing
masks on a limited basis i've had throat
surgery my thyroid out maybe that's part
of it maybe i'm susceptible to it i
don't know
but i got it and i was sick for months
and i could i was pushed i've been
pushed out of stores when my little girl
here was two i'm holding her my arms
it's summer there's like no covert
around in summer 2020 and i'm on
prednisone and
inhalers and azithromycin and zyrtec
throw in the kitchen sink at
my lungs that have been sick for months
and these people they won't let me in
their store pushing me out
uh this
guy at the co-op and keen he's wearing
the study just came out he's wearing the
gator style mask that shows that they
actually nebulizes the droplets into
smaller droplets
and he's wearing his stupid gator which
would make his droplets worse
and he's pushing me out i couldn't even
i'm telling him well my lungs are
damaged i can't wear a mask when i
breathe through a mask
my lungs seize up
even just now at crotchet in
sunapee you're supposed to wear a mask
so i put my balaclava here and i'm in
the the ski shop gonna get here i ran
out of hand warmers weren't getting hand
warmers for my son because it's five
below zero and the guys they're talking
to me and talking through when you talk
you breathe through your mouth
and my lungs start i couldn't i had to
pull the thing down i'm like i'm sorry i
cannot
breathe through this stupid anything my
lungs start seizing up and tickling i
had i would not cover my mouth at
sunapee last march it was like one of
those warm days and my son i won't cover
his mouth we're outside so you can sit
at picnic tables and eat with no mask
but you can't go in the line i had they
wouldn't let me on the left they called
i said fine call the police the police
at a police escort at a son of me with
my eight-year-old who loves police
and he's crying and the ski patrol lady
goes see you made him cry and he goes no
you made me cry
because they ruined him and then they
revoked my past i should have done more
about that but you know that this is the
discrimination that's out there you want
examples i've been pushed out of stores
i've had a police escort with my
eight-year-old because i won't put a
and again if you want your mask to work
they're not if you can put a hair
through your mask it's not working if
you want protection get your vitamin d
tested
okay thank you ms gulliver are there any
thank you for coming today thank you for
i think that's dr gary york is that
correct thank you that's fine thank you
and thank you mr chairman and the rest
of the committee
it really is about discrimination
we've heard some
very emotional testimony from the
previous speaker
i'd like to just address some of the
questions uh comments that were
preceded us
preceded me
one of them was
in regards to accommodations
would it be okay if
a venue decided that they could create a
special place for those who
did not have a vaccine passport maybe
that
in itself is discrimination it goes back
to the separate but equal but it's not
really equal because you're creating a
spot for somebody
and if you don't have to go very far
back to remember places where
uh yeah it will accommodate you but it
has to be
in the back alley after dark or
at a water fountain around the corner or
at the back of the bus so it's about
discrimination
the
other thing i would like to address is
that
four-letter f word again i'm going to
say it out loud fear
as an unvaccinated
physician i would like to
let you know that i am not
evil
ability
special
ability to infect others
because i'm unvaccinated
it's clear that those who have been
vaccinated versus unvaccinated have the
same viral load can spread the disease
vaccines are failing
incredibly
but the fear is there we want to get
everyone vaccinated
this is not a
pandemic of the unvaccinated
we've heard that drilled down so many
times
in order for put the pressure on people
to get vaccinated
and today
we hear the pressure get vaccinated get
it vaccinated
why what is the purpose it's pretty
clear vaccine's not working what
ulterior motive is it to have people
vaccinated
as safe and effective believe me
i spoke to the
[Music]
specifics of the bill in my previous
testimony and that relates to
accommodations that
may
discriminate against
people like me um
and i'll repeat them just for this
specific bill that there is a local
venue that requires uh people to come in
on a special night we'll give you food
and
bring your pass your passports with you
your vaccine passports
and i use that term loosely but um a
vaccination card is nothing more than a
proxy for a vaccine passport and where
are we headed with a vaccine passport or
any kind of passport as far as privacy
goes
to me that's
discrimination is what it is
um i'd like to also comment on
just personal experience about the
discrimination um it relates loosely uh
and not directly to the
to the nature of the bill but i do have
a family member who was uh
was let go of their job
because they refused to have a man
vaccine mandate was imposed on by his
company healthcare company
social worker
he
my child decided not to get the vaccine
his choice
and he had no the
the company did not have any
accommodations
for him to get weekly testing they did
not allow that
and here's more discrimination
if he has to take a test every week then
everyone has to take a test
if
he has to wear a mask everyone has to
wear a mask this is discrimination
otherwise it's clear this is
discrimination there's no other way to
see it as that
go go back a few months where we had
those who are unvaccinated
must wear a mask to enter the store
if you've had a vaccine
you're a special class come on in you
don't need a mask
that's discrimination especially when we
know that the spread of the virus
is no different
from me giving it to you or you giving
it to me
we're all the virus is gonna virus this
is what it does you know no one's
especially immune to viruses
in any particular way that we know of
uh so again another story about
discriminatory practice i have a niece
who is a
oncologist at a large
massachusetts
healthcare
provider that had to leave her job
despite submitting a religious exemption
that was not accepted
she with
the
[Music]
her free will was
in her in her belief was that she was
not going to get the vaccine because of
the obvious dangers that have been
reported
not not widely obviously because still a
lot of people are
uninformed i would say i wouldn't say
she had to leave and now she's having to
move to montana with her family
so again it boils down to discrimination
and i don't know how else uh to say it
but this this is a discriminatory
practice if we allow
public
venues to
require
passports
slash
vaccine cards to enter their building
thank you
questions for dr you
sing none thank you for your testimony
i did get
ms malachi indicated she wanted to
respond to an earlier question but ms
malachi i don't really want to go
through a second round of testimony
today so if you could send us a response
that in the email to the committee that
would be great
okay
and is there anyone who hasn't testified
seeing no one thank thank you we'll
close the hearing on house bill 1490 fn
and the committee will be in recess
until our next hearing which is
wow
yes
being there is now 1 p.m i like to call
the hearing on house bill 1343
and order
and i have one card
so far oh he has more coming but first
to speak
i rec i recognize the sponsor of the
bill representative nick jordan
the prime sponsor what did i say
okay
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee my for the record my name is
ned gordon
i do represent grafton county district 9
which consists of five towns alexandria
ashland bristol bridgewater and grafton
and today i bring to you house bill 1343
it is a bill which creates a pilot
program
to determine whether under limited
circumstances non-attorneys may provide
representation to litigants who are
currently underserved in our circuit
courts
in particular this bill would allow
qualified paralegals working under the
authority of a licensed attorney to
represent clients in certain family
but just by way of background
up until the 1980s virtually all
litigants
in divorce and custody matters were
represented by council
but for a variety of reasons probably
most prominently the cost of attorneys
the trend of self-representation
developed
now in our circuit court
eighty to ninety percent of the people
who appear in the family division are
unrepresented
the court has worked hard to accommodate
this trend
it has established mediation programs
and has attempted to make the legal
process as understandable and as
user-friendly as possible
but still there is no substitute for
legal representation
even if you go on the court website as i
did earlier today you'll see that the
court
tells people that
if at all possible they should receive
and obtain representation
and why is that important
unrepresented parties are clearly
disadvantaged when the other party has
counsel in cases before the court
unrepresented parties are not familiar
with the court rules or procedures
unrepresented parties are often anxious
or intimidated by appearing in court
unrepresented parties often make
unnecessary concessions in order to
avoid the court proceedings
and unfortunately unrepresented parties
do not understand the law
the financial cost of representation is
often a bar for litigants to receive
proper representation
the hourly cost in and of itself may be
prohibited
but in particularly in family court
matters
it's common practice to obtain a
retainer before an attorney will take on
a case
that cost of that retainer is generally
three thousand or four thousand and or
five thousand or maybe more
even people with moderate incomes may
find it difficult to raise the upfront
in addition to that we're currently
obtaining we currently have a crisis
with regard to evictions in this state
and
nationally
and few people can be afforded to be
represented generally these are people
in crisis
over
their rental property they are renters
to begin with and few of them have the
resources in order to obtain an attorney
house bill 1343 would allow for
non-attorneys in certain circumstances
to provide representation to tenants in
i'd note that what this bill does
is
it provides for paralegals who are
qualified either having a
four-year college degree or
a paraprofessional degree a two-year
para
para professional degree and with two
years of experience in the law
to work under the auspices of an
attorney
who is insured
and who would be subject to the rules of
this is means tested
so
it isn't going to be available for
people who can in fact afford those high
retainers or for those hourly fees it's
mean tested to 300 percent of the
poverty rate
so it would be limited to people who
have
the greatest
need
in addition if a non-attorney were to
assist in representing they would have
to provide notice they would have to
provide notice to the client that they
are a non-attorney
and they would have to provide notice to
the court if they're filing pleadings or
appearing in court that they are a
non-attorney
having non-attorneys appear in court is
and i might add that the bill only
provides for a pilot program
just to see if in fact this program will
have value to the state
it would take place in two courts
it would take place in the court in
manchester and the court in berlin both
of these courts have high volumes of
unrepresented
people
it would be one urban court and one more
rural court
and it would be limited to two types of
matters landlord-tenant matters
and family court matters and by fam not
all family court matters but more
specifically divorces
matters non-attorneys again
is appearing in court as not something
new
non-attorneys appear in our courts all
the time in generally in limited roles
new hampshire statute specifically
provides that a person in appearing in
our courts can have a person represent
them of their choice
although we have imposed qualifications
including how many times a person may
appear
generally i think that the standard is
no more than three times in a year
and they have to be a good character so
the court has set rules and that's
another thing that this bill would do
would be allow the court to set rules
uh with regard to the
uh the qualifications of people to
appear
currently we allow police officers
to
participate in our courts
they prosecute cases just like attorneys
and they're not required to have one
we allow domestic violence advocates
we've heard testimony here on earlier
bills with regard to domestic violence
advocates they're not allowed to speak
in the court
but they assist people in providing
legal legal advice to to their
uh
guardian adele items appear regularly in
our court and we rely on them
non-attorney when and we specifically
when we created the guardian at light on
board this when the legislature created
the guardian lighting board
made it so you don't have to be an
attorney to be a guardian enlightenment
in this state because we know that you
don't necessarily have to have the
skills of an attorney to be a good
non-attorneys uh
uh
we you're going to be hearing as well
from
from uh new hampshire legal assistance
here today
but they're already using uh their
paralegals to do or to represent clients
and other types of hearings hearings
before the health and human services
administrative hearings
and very successfully
then that's exactly who you know beca
and
one of the things about the program is
it would be have a limited window
so it's a two-year pilot program
sunsetted
so in two years it would give us an
if it doesn't work we can do away with
it
the
it was interesting to hear the comments
from the representative from the human
rights commission
when she was given a legal question
today who she said she have to consult
with before she gave the answer
there are many capable paralegals out
there and
frankly i don't see this as a situation
where
uh
you're just going to have people who are
now non-attorneys out representing
clients
it's going to be the under the auspices
of an attorney and i the way i certainly
envision this working is you probably
consult with an attorney
and then you work with the paralegal and
the attorney sends the paralegal to
court
to act on behalf of the client
and that would seem to work out
particularly well
frankly the paralegals when i was doing
this type of practice the paralegals
prepared the pleadings for me
they did everything frankly except go to
court
i'm you know i'm well aware that many of
my colleagues who are members of the bar
may object to the bill
and may have concerns that the public
will not be well served
by people who are not formally trained
but one thing i would say is the buyers
and i'd ask what remedy have they
provided
i also would say this is not a panacea i
don't think
all of a sudden we're going to do away
by adopting this program or a program of
this type that we're going to do away
with
with unrepresented clients it just isn't
going to happen
but
it could make a dent in it it could help
it could assist and more people
people that we're supposed to be serving
this is i might add it's a trend across
the country this isn't something that is
unique to new hampshire there are other
states i
have and may have sent out already to
you a
article
about
oregon adopting a very similar type
program
one of the advantages of this program
there
they have allowed paralegals in other
states i think the state of washington
had a program
where
they would allow paralegals to represent
clients in certain matters
but they had a licensing program
and high requirements for the persons to
do that
and it was so complicated and so
difficult
that it was it formed a barrier and
frankly the program wasn't a success
i think the way we've designed it here
would be efficient
practical
and will not create a barrier for people
who want to provide these types of
services
the other thing i'd say is that this is
analogous to what's happened in the
we've seen in recent years the
development of nurse practitioners
and physicians assistants
and i believe that this could work in
new hampshire and that we should make an
effort
it's interesting
because i was in the legislature a long
time ago and this was at a time when
they were talking about having nurse
practitioners and what and having them
just practice to start out just practice
under the auspices of an attorney
whatever
which is evolved from that but the big
issue at that time
was
prescribing medications
because that was the one that was the
one thing that physicians felt made them
that they could hold on that that
protected their practice frankly
and
as time has evolved now nurse
practitioners can prescribe medications
and it's gone down through the line and
i don't think the doctors have suffered
i think the doctors have done just fine
i think the same thing is true because
the one last barrier in the law
is the ability to appear in court
that's the one last barrier
and this would determine whether or not
you can
affect that barrier
and whether it will do any harm to do
i gotta i gotta say that if you had
asked me
uh 20 years ago whether
i thought this was a good idea or not
you know to to be fair to my uh
colleagues in the bar if you asked me 20
years ago whether i thought this was a
good idea i'd say no
i'd be totally against it because i'd
say
you know
i went to college and then i went to
three years of law school hard work
i spent a ton of money
i didn't happen to but a lot of my
colleagues went into a lot of debt to
become lawyers
and
and pass that bar exam to become a
lawyer
and i just don't want somebody else just
to take over and start doing that job
and i think that's probably the way i
felt about it
and the other
the the
and i
don't blame anybody for feeling that way
uh and i think the other argument they'd
make is you know the issue of uh public
safety uh and you know geez you know i
received training in the law and
i expect
in order to protect
the interests of the public
they should be represented by people who
have had adequate training
i can tell you in law school
i certainly came out of law school i did
divorces and
custody matters
before i became a judge
i never learned a damn thing about him
in law school so
because they don't really teach
what it's like to practice they teach
you good things they teach you how to be
logical
they teach you how to speak they teach
you how to appear in court but when it
comes down to those types of really
tough issues that you have to deal with
in the family court you don't really get
that in law school i don't believe
anyway uh the
long and the short
is i think
but my view has changed and my view has
changed over time over those 20 years
and part of the view is being a part of
the legislature
and and that is that i know ultimately
our purpose here is to serve the public
and
i think the public will be better served
if in fact
we allow more people to be represented
in our courts
i think this is a way to go about to see
whether we can do that and i would
encourage you to support the bill
thank you very much
thank you if we have any questions right
over here representative chase
thank you mr chair and
thank you representative gordon for
taking my question
i know this is a pilot program i
see
the good of it what i want to know is
how would that work where we're talking
about saying to retain a lawyer could be
up to three thousand dollars are these
paralegals going to be sitting in the
courtroom and then they're just going to
say hey i can help you will the public
know about it to be able to
have the services provided with them
um do you understand what i'm trying to
say yeah i do okay thank you
um first of all it's a pilot
it's a pilot program
and it's sunsetted so
do i think a lot of private law firms
are going to invest in this program to
begin with
probably not
because they're not going to make a big
investment knowing that it might not end
up forever
i think that there are plenty of law
firms today that have qualified
paralegals
we did a study committee
some members that are sitting here were
on that study committee
two years ago and we had lawyers who
came in and said yeah my paralegal could
go to court tomorrow so there are some
people who could
uh work this to have their paralegals go
to court i believe today but i'm not
sure anybody invested what really i
think where you may see the benefit and
you're going to hear from new hampshire
legal assistance
is they have paralegals right now who
could do this tomorrow
and i think that you're going to see
that they're the ones that probably are
going to the non-profit agencies
603 legal aid
may very well use this program
new hampshire legal assistance
i was talking about the disability
rights center they don't do much court
work right now but i could see this as a
potential for them as well working with
disabilities people with disabilities
and having them represented in court
so
uh that's where
that's where i i think it's going to
happen
representative langley
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative gordon for taking my
question
on line seven you talk about supervision
that would be provided to these
paralegals do you have any sense of what
that supervision would include and the
frequency of it and the amount of time
or
well uh
currently
whenever you have a paraprofessional
working for a lawyer the lawyer has
uh that duty of care and has the
responsibility to provide supervision
that exists today really
and so they the supervision does not
necessarily mean that they have to
accompany them to court
but they would have to take they in
essence are taking responsibility for
their conduct in court okay thank you
they know that they potentially hold the
liability if that paralegal
does not
misperforms
thank you
question from representative dilorenzo
thank you mr clear and thank you for
taking my question um
so would this
program be um
[Music]
would this program be appropriate for a
law student to take part in
we already have a program for law
students called rule 36
and which
that's interesting because
under rule 36 there are certain
requirements
and this might be able to expand the
role of students in certain
circumstances
anybody else yes representative
thank you mr chair for
allowing me the question and thank you
for taking my question um i'm sorry if i
missed this but uh what was the intent
for the
federal poverty guideline yep what was
the intent yes well
it sort of was anticipating an objection
uh from the bar association
that now people
who could afford an attorney would now
be
hiring
someone
to get a
basically just for the purpose of
getting a better rate
and so
i
to avoid them having being threatened i
think that's probably why that was
included
thank you if that makes sense
cnn thank you for your testimony
thank you
next to chair recognizes sarah matson
dustin
how's that
great okay good afternoon mr chair
members of the committee my name is
sarah matson dustin i am an attorney and
the executive director at new hampshire
legal assistance
for those who aren't familiar with nhla
we have been around for about 50 years
and we're a non-profit legal aid
provider which means that we help people
with low income in cases that impact
their basic human needs and i'm very
happy to be here today to speak in
support of house bill 1343.
there is no right to an attorney in most
civil cases
so people facing eviction don't have a
right to an attorney folks who are
litigating a divorce
or their parenting rights to their minor
children don't have a right to an
attorney
and as representative gordon said that
means that the majority of litigants who
are appearing in the circuit court
are doing so while representing
themselves upwards of 90 percent of
tenants
who are facing eviction are going it
alone
in the majority of family law cases so
divorce and custody in the majority of
those both parties are representing
themselves
and some some self-represented litigants
are able to protect their interests
effectively
but others who don't understand the
subject matter or don't understand the
court's complex procedural roles
and are having to do so at a difficult
time in their lives
can struggle to protect their own
interests
we're enthusiastic
about this bill because we see it as an
access to justice measure a way to get
more legal help to people who need it
i think it's really important to
distinguish this pilot project from what
a few other states have done so in utah
washington and arizona there have been
efforts that have resulted in
independent paralegal licensure so
allowing paralegals to practice on their
own
that's still going in utah and in
arizona washington state sunsetted their
program and this is categorically
different
this bill would require paralegals to be
both employed by and supervised by a
licensed attorney has educational
requirements including
both a bachelor's degree or an
associate's degree in a law related
field plus two years of work uh work
experience in a law related setting with
attorney supervision has a disclosure
requirement so both the client and the
court would need to be notified that the
person is not an attorney and given the
name of the supervising attorney
and the supervising attorney
has the obligation to ensure that the
paraprofessional is comporting with the
rules of professional conduct and has to
at our firm
we have paralegal advocates doing what
we call administrative law so they may
be helping someone who is appealing a
social security disability decision
or trying to get unemployment insurance
benefits
or even seeking immigration relief and
these are all settings in which
non-lawyers are explicitly authorized
to be able to represent clients
these are often highly technical
proceedings where the paraprofessional
has to understand the substantive law as
well as
often highly complex administrative
procedural rules
and our paralegal advocates handle these
cases
incredibly capably and with great
success
the other thing i want to note is that
there are really very
very few bars to attorneys representing
clients in court so the day that you are
licensed
you can lawfully
represent someone
who is charged with homicide you can
lawfully represent someone in a million
dollar personal injury lawsuit
now virtually no attorneys would choose
to do that because it would they would
likely not be able to do so competently
but the point that i'm trying to make
is that
a trained paraprofessional with
education experience and supervision can
absolutely do this
with no more risk
to the public than simply simply already
exists
so we would love to
tell you more about nhla and about what
our paralegals do so i'll leave it at
that and invite you to ask any questions
that you have thanks for giving me the
opportunity to speak thank you do we
oh okay representative chase thank you
thanks for taking my question i might
have just
skipped over this but so the paralegal
helps and does all the work for the
client
in this pilot program but then and they
also are allowed then to appear in court
as representation or does the lawyer
then have to step in thanks for the
question so
um so what this pilot would authorize is
for the paralegal actually to provide
representation in the courtroom
so essentially
right now
the first scenario that you described is
what is already permissible
so
if you look at the the bar news which is
the the lawyers trade journal here in
new hampshire that the job postings at
the back
dozens
of opportunities for paralegals across
all practice settings litigation
corporate et cetera so
if you've if you've paid for legal
services in the private market in new
hampshire you have almost certainly
gotten part of what you paid for through
the services of a paralegal
but right now there's just this
invisible line around the courthouse
that says
through here you shall not pass
and
that's what we'd like to have the
opportunity to show that that
paraprofessionals in the family law
setting in the landlord attendance
setting um can
can could do a good job and it's really
not
it's not about whether someone's going
to have a lawyer or a paralegal this
bill is about whether someone's going to
have a paralegal or they're going to
have nothing
and so
it
it would get rid of that invisible line
and give us a chance to show that this
can be done in a way that will
help some people and and maintain
and okay question over here
representative sylvia thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
regarding the attorneys that are
it doesn't really speak to exactly
how closely they are
supervising
what
what would
be a reasonable assumption as far as the
number of paraprofessionals that might
be working under one attorney
and the
generally the level of supervision that
you
envision
so that's an excellent question thanks
for asking it uh and the answer is that
i don't know and that's because this
obligation already exists for new
hampshire attorneys so the our rules of
professional conduct basically are
ethical rules that are promulgated by
the supreme court
create supervisory obligations both for
attorneys who are managers of their law
firms
as well
over other attorneys what is in our
rules called subordinate attorneys as
well as for non-lawyer assistance which
includes everyone from a paralegal
to the receptionist
and
as far as i know
the
the bar in new hampshire has never
sought more guidance from the supreme
court or from the legislature about how
that obligation has to be exercised so i
our law firm paralegals are supervised
in the same way that other attorneys are
so they're
and for us it varies geographically we
have a tiny office in berlin in a big
office in manchester
but i think it would it's going to
depend on the paralegal's level of
experience so a 10-year paralegal is not
going to need the same amount of
supervision that a two-year paralegal is
and also on the complexity of the work
that's being done
a a complex family law case may require
a great deal more trial prep than a
fairly straightforward non-payment
eviction case so i wish i could give you
a you know it's got to be 10 to 1
or less but i think it really
both does depend on the practice setting
and the experience of the people
involved and is a question that that
already is unanswered for a lot of
representative lorenzo thank you mr
chairman
thank you miss matson dutston um so
could we talk about um
how the public would be protected if
they have a paralegal representing them
thank you sir absolutely thanks for the
question
so i think there's there's two different
pieces to think about one is
professional liability and the other is
ethical violations
so in the situation where there's an
allegation of malpractice
the
the person who is liable there is the
firm so if a client were to sue new
hampshire legal assistance which we
always are hoping is not going to happen
the lawsuit is against the firm it's not
against the individual lawyer and this
bill would
because it requires
the paraprofessionals to be employed by
a firm would mean that liability would
lie in that case with the firm as well
and this has a requirement of of
professional liability insurance
coverage so
as in any other setting the the insurer
would would defend and the policy limits
would apply ethical violations are a
little bit different because an ethical
violation of an individual practitioner
at a law firm
do not extend to all the other members
of the firm and
the rules of professional conduct that i
referenced before are pretty specific
about when
an ethical violation of someone that a
lawyer is supervising
essentially attaches to the supervising
lawyer
so for example a supervising lawyer has
the obligation to try to prevent or
mitigate
but is not
is not necessarily liable for um
for something that they couldn't have
foreseen happening i think that this
bill goes a little bit farther by making
it
clear that there are um
there's a statutory obligation as well
to ensure
the reasonable conduct of the paralegal
in addition to the
the ethical obligation that
anyone else
questions
cnn thank you for your testimony thank
you
we have anybody else who would like to
testify
on house bill 1343
cnn i will close a hearing on house bill
yes yes thank you uh yeah we are in
recess until 2 30. we have quite a bit
of time between now and 2 30.
where you're in recess
um
good afternoon everyone we'll call the
house judiciary committee back to order
our next item on the agenda is a hearing
on house bill 1205 an act allowing the
department of environmental services to
have access to enhanced 911 information
the prime sponsor of that bill is
representative podecic and i understand
he's here available he can introduce his
thank you mr chairman and honorable
members of the judiciary committee
it's nice to be before you and see so
many people in this room that i haven't
seen in a while
um allow me to introduce house bill 1205
which is the exact same bill as house
bill 2019-hb
h
this is the bill that was before us and
passed through this committee and the
house two years ago
then went on to the senate to an
untimely death because the house and
senate could not agree to the senate
amendments
it's a bipartisan bill
allowing des to have access to enhanced
911 information
it is
also
for
the technical side of this bill and
addre to address the
address and longitude and latitude of
information without any personal names
attached
mr
tim bethke my technical uh aide on this
will be testifying next
uh about the technical portion of this
bill i was asked by him to introduce it
to get this ball rolling
and with that i have gotten the ball
rolling
and
will take any rough in for
are there any questions for the
representative
saying none thank you for your testimony
thank you mr chairman
and we will call upon tim bethke
i do have copies of my testimony along
with some other information if you like
i don't think you need to pass it out
now we'll listen to your testimony you
can hand it in at the end if you want
unless you prefer to do it now nope
sounds sounds fine so make sure i pass
off the information first
good afternoon members of the judiciary
committee and fellow citizens of new
hampshire my name is tim bethke i'm a
resident of auburn new hampshire and
lived in new hampshire for the last 20
years
i'm an employee of tomtom north america
which is based in lebanon new hampshire
and worked as a regional sourcing
researcher
for the last 18 years
tomtom is a global digital mapping
company that provides geolocation
technology for drivers car makers
enterprisers
developers
as part of my job i make sure that the
tomtom map is as accurate as possible
for customers such as uber microsoft
verizon nissan precisely among others
which ultimately benefit the general
public in terms of railway safety and
i'm here today to show support for the
new hampshire house bill 1205 and to the
department of environmental services and
to the department of safety division of
emergency services and communications
i'm also here to advocate for openness
of the emergency
emergency management 9-1-1 address point
data with basic non-sensitive
geo-located addresses to state agencies
commercial companies
and to other entities that request it
our new england state neighbors vermont
maine new hampshire
sorry my
let me rephrase that
our new england state neighbors vermont
maine rhode island and new york provide
address point data through open data
portals
massachusetts provides azure data data
through an online request
form and connecticut provides address
data through email requests
there are numerous reasons why
the new hampshire address point data
should be made available
accurate data mail accurate data
available to emergency agencies
organizations accompanies vital when
seconds count
it helps with tourism in the state and
allows local visitors accurate
navigation to their final destinations
or to various tourist destinations
transparency in allowing other groups
with this data is also vitally important
efficiency
help with various
service industries with accurate routing
and also avoid other offices from
duplicating efforts
addressing is the most basic
form of and fundamental piece of
the average consumer uses tomtom apple
maps google or waze as it's also known
as etcetera for navigation and location
those commercial companies provide
authoritative local those data providers
need authoritative local data
local data is the best data
in our current technology state data is
available everywhere even addressing
data
is far better to have data that comes
from the authoritative source than from
a third party vendor
states not states with data not in the
according to a local emergency expert in
new hampshire former fire chief of the
town of auburn and current emt at ghana
explained to me that most volunteer emts
and firefighters are expected to know
how to navigate to an emergency in their
community
in some cases volunteers are not
provided with their computers or
navigation navigation systems that are
available in emergency vehicles
volunteers often rely on commercial
navigation apps on their mobile phones
to get to the emergency location
tomtom and other commercial mapping
companies provide that map data to power
that that powers
navigation apps used in emergency
situations
i'm here today seeking an amendment to
the house bill 1205 to make available
emergency emergency management 911
address point data with the basic
non-sensitive geolocated addresses to
state agencies commercial companies and
other entities that request it
that concludes my statement
yes representative horrigan
um
yes
is it true if i recall correctly that a
one of the corporate predecessors today
tomtom geographic data technology was
actually the
uh compiled the first uh nationwide
address databases with the uh
with the house numbers um
on at least as many of the
segments of highways as possible
yes yes sir um i was originally a gdt
employee
then it became tally atlas and now it's
known as tom tom yes i i spent a i spent
a little time there not as much as you
did but
yes it was quite exciting thanks i've um
i did that commute from auburn slash
dairy new hampshire to lebanon for two
and a half years before i finally said
hey can i work from home and i've been
remote since then oh good choice i only
had to commute from orford to to lime so
it wasn't quite as bad
thank you very much for your testimony
today
brandon
kernan
thank you chairman and members of the
committee i'm brandon kernan i'm the
administrator of the drinking water and
groundwater bureau at the department of
environmental services we're here to
testify in support of the bill today and
also as you'll note in our
testimony letter to request a small
since 2006 state law has been changed to
allow department of environmental
services to have
very limited access to the e-91 data set
and the access we have is essentially
an address and a longitude and latitude
and so it's really a near perfect set of
addresses for the state of new hampshire
and we worked with the legislature and
department of safety back in 2006 to get
access to this
because we had a real urgent need for
the information at the department one of
the things the department that we
oversee
is the construction of water wells and
in the state there's about a quarter
million what private water wells in the
state
and when people are proposing new large
groundwater extractions state law
requires that we identify nearby wells
and that we assure we assess impacts to
those wells before we approve a new
withdrawal
and so
by having this information 9-1-1 we're
able to take our well records paper well
records which are entered into database
and match it with the address of 9-1-1
and locate the dots all over the map
thus seeing where the wells are and so
it saves a lot of work and ensures we're
very thorough in assessing impacts
more recently the data has been urgent
in identifying where private wells are
in southern new hampshire you know the
population center of our state is
contaminated with pfas due to air
emissions
and we have teams every day every day
since 2016 that are out there and
sampling private wells about thousand to
date and we have a backlog
and again this data helps us identify
where the private wells are if you have
an address
um in an area and you don't have a map
water supply line you can
guess that there's a private well there
because you a property that has an
address and what swelling would have a
water supply and so if there's no mapped
water lines we can find the private
wells
contact the homeowners and if they want
sample their well at no cost and help
them with alternative water another
thing that we needed access to this data
for was improving our understanding of
hydrogeology throughout the state the
well drillers submit a record to us
every time they drill a well
it has an address on it
and that record shows things like depth
of bedrock the type of soil stratigraphy
that you have the well yield and by by
being able to match those paper records
and the technical information on there
with the e911 vocational data all sudden
you can create cross-sections and maps
of the state to help with water water
resource studies which is critical for
communities and throughout the state as
they try to develop new water resources
so it served us very well the data's
been controlled we only use it for the
purposes i have we cannot share it with
others even at a right to know
this bill kind of rewords things to make
more clear what the department has
access to and when safety has to provide
it and we're fine with that approach
but we have one more need for this data
based on some federal requirements and
that's where we ask for the amendment
right now the statute says we can access
e911 data to locate private wells and
that's all we're using it for
but now per us epa we have to develop
lead service line inventories for every
service connection to a public water
system in the state by october 2024
and so you'll see on the second page of
the letter and there's a map
and that's the kind of data we're going
to have to generate for
potentially a few hundred thousand sites
in the state an inventory of every line
associated with the water system going
to a dwelling and identify if it has a
lead service line if it might have lead
joints if it's galvanized that might
require replacement because of some like
components
and then ultimately we have to work the
water systems to come up with plans to
replace all those lead service lines
the federal government has put 150
million dollars towards this for new
hampshire for the next five years and so
we have money to start working on the
inventories
and the replacement of those lines
having this address that um data set for
this purpose gives us a really clean
starting point i mean one way or another
we're gonna have a list of addresses for
the federal requirements but with the
perfect naming convention
um you know streets being spelled out
versus abbreviated and having the
location information it just gives us a
really clean base to start from so we
don't have to recreate the wheel and
frankly with something to be less it
would be imp less perfect than what we
have with the 911 data again it would be
controlled where we're not looking for
any personal information or structural
value information or anything it's just
the longitude latitude and dots just
like we have now for wells and just like
you kind of see on that map
on the second page of the letter
yes representative lorenzo thank you for
taking my question and thank you mr
chairman um as far as the lead pipes and
lead lines has there ever been like a
cut off as to when
you know builders could
have to stop using lead and making lines
it there's been steady um improvements
in the federal state drinking water act
that have limited amount of lead it's
never been a clean cut off
but over time and i could give you the
history of it the percentage of the
components that had lead have been
reduced over and over the most recent
one
fixed a big problem where it said the
lead can't be in the wetted area of a
fixture and that was even though it was
a small percentage it was still getting
in the water
but uh
yeah i mean going forward new
construction does not have lead but it's
all over the place going back in time
especially from the 60s on
i did have one question on the bill and
that is in the current law
it makes a specific provision that says
the department of environmental services
shall not release
shared data under rsa 91a
and then in the proposal it also
indicates that
data wouldn't be released under 91a but
in your amendment
it doesn't specifically provide for that
even though i know you said that
our amendments intended just to add
language to say in addition to private
wells led service lines and we're not
trying to alter
the other provisions of the existing law
that we as the amendment wasn't whole
for the whole proposed bill it was just
for that one section talking about what
we can do with the
data
okay i think i understand
representative langley
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um on line 26 you are on line 28 you
talk about the resources
um the demand
from the department in terms of
deleting the data that won't be sent
over just the addre the addresses and
location will be sent over do you are
you going to have the resources
available to
delete the remaining data that's in the
911 information so that it can be sent
over to your department
or will do you know if they have that
resource yes it's um quite easy to
to restrict data it's in data and
columns and you essentially pick the
columns that you want to transfer and so
already when we have safety for the
information not to minimize the level of
effort
within a usually a few hours the data is
ready and it's just the longitude
latitude and the address it's no effort
to really strip it thank you
any other questions
representative horrigan
thank you very much mr chair of
there are already
commercial databases that have a vast
majority of the street addresses in new
hampshire and nationwide
maps spotted
so let's see uh
let's see so i guess the advantage of
this database is uh the cost would be
uh nominal or probably free and then
it's more accurate data or what is that
why you do that why you want to do this
or is there something preventing you
from using
you know like google maps
there's a database there and then
there's openstreetmap and other
databases so
looks like mr pesky is
that's gesturing too that's a great
question
so there would be a cost we are funded
to do this work and if we ever lost
access to the normal data we would go
spend the money on inferior data from
the private companies
the beauty of 9-1-1 is that someone has
gone out and taken measurements and
located that driveway cut that building
so you know it's accurate where
these other commercial services are
interpolating and they're pretty
accurate don't get me wrong but they can
can be way off at times and just because
they haven't actually gone out in truth
each address as required by 9-1-1 really
when they you set that up in a town
questions
see none thank you for your testimony
i'm
not sure i can figure it out entirely
yeah
and you could tell us your first name
would be helpful certainly good
afternoon my name is mark doyle i'm the
director of the division of emergency
services and communications
at the new hampshire department of
safety overseeing e911
and we've heard a lot of talk today
about addresses and and verification why
it's so important for
the two entities behind me environmental
services and the gentleman from tomtom
to have accurate
address information and i always like to
hear anecdotally the stories about why
everybody wants access to e911's
information and what's difference
between ours and google maps and apple
maps and the like well frankly as you
just heard
ours is verified meaning we physically
send somebody to every address in the
state before it's actually put on the
town roll to make sure that that address
exists that there's a location
identified with it that there's a curb
cut matching that address location and
at this longitudinal attitude associated
with it
and not downplaying apple maps or google
maps but the reason we do that we go to
that extremes because our first
responder stakeholders our partners rely
on that to make sure that we can
provision them and they can provision
emergency services
to any physical address in town
the town that they're responding to and
have jurisdiction over
when we spoke with the folks at
environmental services about this
particular amendment obviously our
concern was making sure that any
information that we provide to any
entity
is confidential
in the event that any personally
identifiable information goes along with
that data stream so when we talk to the
folks at environmental services as you
had just heard they're looking for
literally just a plot on the map that
has an address affixed to a street and a
longitudinal attitude that goes along
with it which is something that we can
do in with very little difficulty that
we currently provide them upon request
the one thing that we always want to
make sure of though is that whenever we
provision any information like that that
it's safeguarded and controlled and the
folks at environmental services have
done a remarkable job of making sure
that that information is confidential
and held in the highest regard when it
comes to maintaining it and that you
always get hurt as well it's not
available through a 91a request per
statute
much the way 91a
requests
aren't available to anybody petitioning
e911 for those records we have the same
confidentiality associated with the
records that we have that we hold that
we create and that we provision in this
case at least department of
environmental services
nothing should really change too too
much with regard to our ability to
provide that information we will work
closely with them to find out exactly
what it is that they're looking for if
it's anything different
but we'll make sure that any provision
or any information that we do provide to
environmental services will be in such a
way that it'll be confidentially handled
and then it will be maintained in a
confidential manner
and that it will be
dealt with accordingly in the event that
it has to be destroyed or discarded
part one
part two when i had an opportunity just
at the very last minute the 12th hour
yesterday to talk to tim bethke from
time time
we talked very quickly about what it is
that he's looking for to be able to
allow people that are using that
navigation system to use the accurate
data that is available
right now out there which as you heard
isn't i don't want to say as reliable
but again i like to hear that it's
verified address information it's true
to form and it's something that maybe
other entities would like to have access
to as well our concern with is that it
potentially could be a slippery slope
and what is it exactly that they are
looking for if we're provisioning
information such as center line data
which is an address point on a street
the center line of the street that's one
thing but if we're
provisioning address data which is very
more much more or could potentially be
much more detailed meaning street
addresses based upon driveways and long
driveways and private roads and in some
cases we've actually gone to the degree
to allow first responders greater access
and far more detailed access to that
information
building information in terms of attra
access to and entrances to and egresses
from specific buildings that's much more
detailed information that i do not feel
comfortable providing to anybody outside
of e-911 and the first responder
community that we work with what i would
like to do is have an opportunity to
speak in greater detail with uh tim to
find out if there's any more information
that they're looking for in terms of
just centerline data that we're going to
be providing to environmental services
at least in this particular case based
upon the amendment that they want to
make
i'm available for any questions that any
folks might have
are there questions yes
representative smith
in
those circumstances where you are
providing or might be providing
information
um to an entity other than
another state agency
are you
charging
for
providing that information
thank you for your question that it's
actually a very good question because
right now we don't provide any
information to any other agency other
than a state or local agency when they
request it the only time that we can
provide a local agency with that
information
is based upon a request from a town or
assessing department that needs that
information for accurate address
verification or for a local law
enforcement agency that's conducting a
law enforcement investigation and needs
our records pursuant to an investigation
and no we do not charge anybody for that
information
good follow-up you may and is that
because
you are dealing with
other public
and would that position change if you
were
entities that aren't part of the state
or local government
thank you for the question another good
question and to be honest with you we've
not explored that option at all and the
answer to your first part of the
question is yes we've never
considered or even thought about
charging another state agency or a local
agency that relies on on our our data we
look at it as because of the necessary
response required
for a 9-1-1 action
we want to make sure that people are
getting there and don't are not going to
be held up because they couldn't afford
to pay for data that we're provisioning
to them it's going to be out there it's
something that they're already
paying for in a more or less example
that uh
that every town and entity has
mike in my 911 to charge a jurisdiction
for the data that we should be providing
to them anyway so that the citizens of
this state get only the highest level in
quality of service from their first
responders that we can assist in doing
so thank you
other questions
representative sylvia
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
just uh looking for some kind of
background on
the and i don't know how if you're
you've been with the
agency long enough to know the history
of
the origin of the
e-911
and
perhaps discussions about collecting
this data and concerns about privacy
where their assurance is given that this
data would be kept
totally within your system at the time
and thank you for the question and there
were we have
a lot of historical
documentation from back in the mid and
early 90s when e911 was brought up to
operation
and a lot of the discussion that
happened from the then director to a lot
of the city and town councils and town
fathers and
managers and mayors in these cities that
we went to to talk to
public safety entities and local
jurisdictions about what 9-1-1 was and
the concerns that a lot of folks would
have were
just that would our confidential
information about our addresses and like
be
disclosed and how are we going to
collect that information a lot of work
went into making sure that people were
aware in the various towns and cities
the 200 plus that we visited around the
state back in the early 90s to make sure
that they were aware that was going to
be coming and what the reasons were
behind what it was that we were doing so
much so that in the event that there
were questions our personnel our field
representatives our address collection
team uh we're told that
you would maybe needed to have a police
escort because people do not trust maybe
government coming onto their property or
an unknown vehicle driving up their
driveway and the like we made sure that
the vehicles that they were all using
were marked accordingly had a yellow
light on the roof where white had giant
door seals on the side representing who
they were representing that they were
from the department of safety so we
worked a lot on making sure that the
messaging that was appropriate to the
job that we were undertaking was out
there so folks would have the ability to
know it ahead of time
and know that the information that we're
collecting because of the meetings that
we held
yes you can follow up
so
if i go back in my memory to the
early 90s
gps was
kind of newish for the consumer level
and telephone technology was
i can't imagine or can you tell me what
what people envisioned at that time as
far as this technology going forward
i think the short answer is i wasn't at
9-1-1 then i've been the director since
uh 2017 but i worked in the first
responder community
in law enforcement for the previous 32
years before that and i can tell you
that
then what we thought was going to be on
the horizon isn't close to where it
ended up being on the horizon
there's always this vision of where you
think that technology is going to go and
how it's going to drive your response as
a first responder and as first
responders went and we're available you
always try to take advantage of the
latest and greatest technology to make
sure that again you're providing that
level of service that you need to and
that your citizens expect you to 911 is
part of that equation too and what we
wanted to make sure was when we're
looking forward how would 9-1-1 play
into that so when it came to longitude
latitude when it came to tr point
gps capabilities and gps capabilities
were rough then
they're very good now
but there's always room for improvement
and we knew that having gps capabilities
accessible to us whether it was in the
car in the fire truck in the ambulance
or whether it was going to be available
because 911 was giving it to us was
something we would certainly be wanting
to take advantage of and we have been
able to i mean
if need be i can give you dozens of
stories about how gps location has
helped people around the state from car
accidents to where they don't know where
they are to wilderness rescues etc
there's there's a lot of information
that goes into that gps talk technology
that we take advantage of we map
though and we layer over that gps
technology the maps and the addresses
that we verify and create for the entire
state and that's where that 9-1-1 piece
so back to the previous question
i think that
it was it was
there was a lot of confidence placed in
your
you're keeping this data private
does this
in your mind seem to be uh kind of
contrary to the the promises that were
made
in the in one instance it does in one
instance it doesn't depending upon the
type of data that
anybody might be looking for we talk
about centerline data that's one thing
that's stuff that's out there in the
public domain and even
address information is out there in the
public domain if you know where to look
for it if you can go on to
assessing sites around the state gis
sites around the state for local
jurisdictions with a little work you can
dig deep and to find out where people
live and what their addresses are and
what kind of house they're living in and
what the appraisal is and those kinds of
things
and maybe even to the degree that you
might be able to see
uh blueprints of homes or buildings i
mean some some towns may offer that up
as well but it would require a little
bit of investigation a little bit more
work than what we're currently being
able to provide to our
our public safety stakeholders which is
the entire state map right out of the
we don't want to be in a position where
to your point
we've made assurances and promises all
along
to let folks know that there's
confidentiality associated with the work
that we have done
and then go back on that by saying well
we're going to provision that
information only but to the other matter
is that when we talk about that center
line data that's just very basic data
information dots on a map that you
already heard from
mr harris at des talk a little bit about
that's something that we could provide
automatically that doesn't release any
of that confidentiality that we made
assurances of before
thank you
i guess my question is have you seen the
amendment that was proposed by
environmental
services i have
the one reference to line 14
yes
i have
and
i guess the question is is that
acceptable to you
it is
and
if i could just follow up on that the
this replaces what was previously in
part b
of that paragraph
and
where it previously referenced that
the data not be
uh
released under 91a would you have any
objection if that provision was added in
see none thank you for your testimony mr
doyle thank you very much good afternoon
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
i'll let you come up again if long as
you're not going to repeat go over the
same things you said before if you have
thank you mr chairman um a couple things
i wanted to bring up real quickly was
so where i live in new hampshire auburn
there's a couple of addresses that are
right on the border one being winchester
terrace ones being winchester
away
if you were to plug that into your gps
today it would ask you which direction
you want to go winchester terrace or
winchester ave
winchester uh avenue or a winchester way
is on
in out in auburn whereas winchester
terrace is in
derry
if you were to if you were having a
pizza delivered to your house it would
be delivered to
right now to terrace because the address
of winchester way is not in the database
if it wasn't for my work with tomtom
that address would not be in most
navigation systems today
the other example i will give in regards
to address points data is
i've been with the company obviously for
18 years and one of the examples i can
give you is
i dealt with virginia for the longest
time
there's a county in virginia that
provided me with everybody's personal
information i immediately looked at that
information and said
this is not right
i should not have this information this
is the early stages of when gps was just
coming out with address information
i immediately went to my boss said hey
i'm going to contact this county tell
them i'm removing that personal
information i went in there and deleted
all that personal information because i
felt that was the right thing to do
i know for a fact that if there was
personal information in the data that
was given to me by the state of new
hampshire
that we would do the right thing
i can tell you right now what i've done
in the last probably 10 years is gone to
most municipalities in the state of new
hampshire that have have available
partial address data and try to create
recreate the wheel
taking the personal the property
identification number and matching it to
the publicly available parcel data
that that interest information is not
totally accurate
because that's putting you at a pinpoint
in a property that could be
many acres wide
when seconds count that's one
information that is vitally necessary
the address information that the 911
would be providing would be able to
allow people to be navigated correctly
especially first responders
so
i would personally would love to be able
to see that address information
available
minus any personal information all i
want to know is the latin long and that
physical address i don't care who lives
there i don't care how much the property
is i don't care any anything else
if i wanted to i would go into access
gis or any of the other publicly
available parcel databases and utilize
that information
thank you again for your testimony mr
bethke
anyone else
seeing no one i'll declare the hearing
on house bill 1205
closed
i would i just wanted to note for the
record my
my
in terms of compliment i have my son
works for 9-1-1 he does mapping for
9-1-1 actually and but i don't i don't
think he has anything at stake or
anything riskier and i don't they
in any event
um
the committee will be in recess until
tomorrow morning at nine o'clock i just
wanted to tell the committee we do have
um
i've scheduled
executive session for next thursday the
third
for all of the bills that we have heard
so far
my intention is to have a
caucus at least for
the republicans on the second
here in this room at nine o'clock and
um
the
but the uh
all of the bills that we've heard so far
have been scheduled for executive
session i hope to go through them
there's only one bill that we're
required to get out at this point in
time because it requires a second
committee and we'll hear that bill first
when he goes through the executive
session and my intent would be to go
through the other bills
in order
lowest first
unless somebody
has wants to move to hear one of the
other bills earlier and dispose of it
and then we could do that and
if at people's request but otherwise
we'll just go through them in order
and
that's it i guess we're in recess until
tomorrow morning
i i thought you were bringing the lunch
but
thanks
you